foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
autocrats only understand
one word no
no no no no no
I would add a little bit of um spice to
Joe Biden's quote there from his speech
in Poland I would add [__] no
you can [__] all the way off if you're
an autocrat no you're not you're not
going to take a Sovereign Nation like
Ukraine it's not gonna happen he says
Ukraine will never be a victory for
Russia never
you can [__] all the way off
is what Joe Biden told Vladimir Putin
this morning
from Poland from Warsaw
as Joe Biden showed his strength and
liberal democracies strength around the
world by preempting Putin's speech what
what you know I
I really miscalculated how important Joe
Biden's walking through the streets in
the courtyard with the bomb raid
National bomb raid xyron's going off I
really underestimated it and the reason
why is because I didn't know exactly
what Putin was gonna say but apparently
the bite Administration has really good
spies in Russia and they knew exactly
what that [__] was gonna say
folks I don't know if you know this or
not but Putin is a [__] ass [__] why
do you think [__] ass [__] here in
this country love him
and capitulate to his to his autocratic
ways because they are [__] ass [__]
this is um this is a sign that Putin is
reaching his end now it may take a while
it may take a while but Putin's getting
close to the India and the longer he
lets this
um this war crimes go on that he is
committing in Ukraine the shorter his
reign will be
I I don't know if if that signal isn't
quite sent yet especially to the
boneheads on the right wing in this
country who love dictators oh they
[__] love them some dictators so much
so that Donald Trump is making
propaganda videos about education police
I'm going to talk about that today too
but our president in the United States
someone who's oh he's old he's weak he's
feeble
this morning in his speech he gave
Vladimir Putin two middle fingers and
basically said yeah that nuclear war
thing that you're trying to threaten you
can shove it up your [__] ass
you can take your nukes and shove them
up your [__] ass and I dare China to
give them weapons
I dare China because that's what he's
saying he said Ukraine will never
be a victory for Russia never
he is sending a signal around the world
that Western liberal democracy is going
to stand with Ukraine
they're gonna stand with Ukraine
they're going to provide weapons and
arms for Ukraine to defeat Russia
it's not complicated and understand it's
not complicated to see the language that
President Biden is using
you know I talk about this a lot and I
know I'm I'm on repeat here but it Bears
repeating over and over and over and
over again
liberalism is not weak
authoritarianism is weak if you bend to
authoritarians it is weak
[__] weak sauce we watched it last
night I'm gonna show you a clip of
Tucker Carlson
genuflecting
genuflecting to Putin
and Putin's propaganda here
and you know everyone wants to um call
it Russian propaganda which is a you
know good Buzz phrase
but Putin's propaganda is the propaganda
that is mind [__] Russians into
believing [__] that just isn't true this
is what a autocracies do this is what
authoritarian murderous dictators do
they mind [__] their their their
population
into believing their lies and I believe
with the speech that Putin gave I
actually believe that that guy has
convinced himself
of his lives just like Trump has
convinced himself of his own [__]
lies this is what happens they get
delusional they get isolated
Hitler did the same [__] thing
Hitler was making all kinds of decisions
at the end of the second world war in
Europe
that were not based in any kind of
reality
that's why that's why some of the Nazis
were trying to murder that [__]
trying to assassinate him
because he was absolutely down a rabbit
hole that was not going to end well for
themselves
and I would imagine that the longer
Putin goes on
with this with this war in Ukraine where
he's murdering civilians because he has
no other way to gain any kind of any
kind of advantage
other than committing war crimes to
terrify the population in Ukraine
I would imagine that his Reign is
getting smaller and smaller I mean you
know maybe the guy eats an ammo sandwich
or something I don't know
this is usually usually they either eat
the ammo sandwich themselves or their
fed and ammo sandwich
that's usually what happens to murderous
[__] dictators who commit war crimes
on a neighboring Sovereign Nation
and killing civilians murdering them
because you want to gain an advantage
and this whole idea
this whole idea that NATO is the enemy
and and and watching Tucker Carlson
Marjorie Taylor green and the other
[__] real America First Nazis in this
country perpetuate that [__] is
laughable [__] laughable
everyone said when Trump was like oh we
need to hold NATO accountable and make
them pay their weight and blah blah blah
everyone was like well you know maybe
maybe he's got a point maybe you know
he's just be he's just being Trump blah
blah blah yeah could he smackity listen
the reason why Putin is in the position
that he's in where he's doing what he's
doing is because our population elected
and autocorrect
and they continue to play footsie with
that [__] that is why Putin has
any kind of [__] footing in his
narrative at all
we have American we have Congress people
in this we have elected members of
Congress who are who are basically
siding with our [__] enemy of
democracy because they [__] hate
democracy
anyone who's out there pushing Russian
propaganda at all at all in this
conflict of Russia and Ukraine oh well
it's NATO NATO did this NATO did that
you would not have Finland and Sweden
running to Nato
if NATO was the enemy
you [__] boneheads
they're trying to protect their citizens
they're trying to protect their country
from being shelled like Ukraine from a
murderous [__] dictator who has lost
his goddamn marbles actually he didn't
lose his marbles Putin's marbles packed
their [__] and [__] left they got
tired of that [__]
that's how bad it is
I don't know if you listened to any part
of the street I don't speak Russian
but I listened to some of the
translations of Putin speech the
craziest part is it was right-wing
accounts posting this [__] on Twitter
they're like yeah Putin
what okay this is [__] this is listen
it's not right when they're Russian
accounts okay
all the all the Trump I love Trump manga
accounts you're like God damn there's so
many Trump supporters on on Twitter
they're they're Russians
what the [__] are you gonna what what am
I gonna do what am I supposed to do am I
supposed to [__] beat around the bush
you think you come here to watch the
Tony Michaels podcast listen to my show
and think I'm gonna beat around the bush
not just tell you how I think it is [__]
them
but all the while all the while you have
um Putin spending his life even if you
watch the audience like the audience
takes the shots of the audience during
the speech woo baby they're not even
buying that [__] I mean they know it's
all [__] but at least they can be
like yeah whoa yeah oh my god oh I mean
you know the craziest part to me is that
the Trump cult the Maga cult here in
America like the it's it's not a large
percentage of people right like yeah you
know it's below 12 I believe it's
probably dwindling below 10 at this
point as Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump
battle it out for the Republican
nomination it's going to dwindle down
even more
but at least at least
still in this country I mean Trump
hadn't been in power that long Boone's
been in power for a long time over there
and he's murdered a lot of people and
they know they've murdered a lot of
people you think they'd have a little
more enthusiasm or at least
pretend to have here in this country oh
God damn I showed you a video uh was it
last week hell I don't know I can't keep
[__] track with these morons uh of uh
Donald Trump down at Mar-A-Lago saying
that Kerry Lake won Kerry Lake was in
the audience like yeah she won by a lot
and never I was like yeah like at least
they pretend to be enthusiastic
at this point I mean they ain't got much
longer for that enthusiasm to last this
[__] is going to lose again
did you did you see the video
of him describing an education police
where he basically basically what he
wants to do is have the Trump youth you
remember the um the history from it was
Europe
um I believe it was you know the late
20s into the 30s
up till about oh I don't know
1944 1945 something like that in uh in a
in a little country in Europe called
Germany uh there was a dude
um his name is right on the tip of my
tongue um Kanye West talks about him a
lot I think his name is Hitler
he um
oh my God this guy I swear to God
I think I really do think that Trump's
team with Liz Harrington has been coming
and watching this show when we when me
and Gabe Sanchez break down each one of
these [__] videos from Mar-A-Lago but
he does I swear to God there's no way
they're not watching
I know it sounds crazy like Tony do you
think Liz Harrington's coming and why I
I really actually think she's coming to
get pointers
on how to make these [__] videos
better well I mean you know quote better
I mean oh [__] we get the laugh I think
this video is so hilarious and the
reason why it's so hilarious is because
what what Trump is doing is so obvious
he is trying to make sure that Ron
DeSantis has no entry into this race at
all whatsoever like Ronda Santos is like
get rid of all books get rid of all
books in Florida and if a teacher has
books we'll put them in prison
and Donald Trump's like oh we'll hold my
beer we'll put the [__] kids in
prison like what the [__] are you people
talking about
I'm dead serious I'm I'm not kidding you
if you if you haven't heard this video
yet he is basically saying we are going
to have an education police and we are
going to I don't know gestapo's gazpacho
soup Style
discipline our children like what in the
[__] whoa I mean there's a lot of states
that still have corporal punishment in
schools I'm serious it's true there are
schools all around the country that the
principal can get a paddle Off the Wall
wouldn't paddle off the wall and spank a
kid that's a [__] thing still in this
country
an administrative official can [__]
can physically hit a child for
punishment
in some states some states it's outlawed
but some states it's still real I
remember when I was a kid there was a
[__] pedal on the wall in the
principal's office
I only went there a couple times
a week anyways so back to the education
police I would have been in big trouble
um under Trump's authoritarian rule as a
kid I would have been in serious trouble
oh I questioned Authority like a
[__]
I don't know if you noticed that but I
don't give a [__] if you're not
questioning Authority then you're not
doing this whole democracy thing
correctly you're just you're just not
doing it correctly you must question
authority
anyways so Donald Trump we're gonna
watch this video today I promise you
we're gonna watch this video the other
video I want to show you today that is a
highlight that I found uh it's a gym oh
boy it's [__] Jim
it's a gym
from Marjorie Taylor green
um Patriot takes post of this video uh
earlier this seems like an old video
I mean she would still say the same [__]
today I'm not sure where this is from or
when this is from
but Marjorie Marjorie Taylor hoof foot
green otherwise known as the petty Yeti
I referred to her as the [__] ass pipe
bombing [__] this morning because she's
crying about how white men have it bad
in this I'm not I'm not kidding you this
video the entire video is about how
white men
have it hard
white men got it difficult in this look
as a white dude I'm here to tell you
that is all 100 [__] and I've heard
white dudes tell me this before
I've heard white dudes tell me this [__]
to my face
like yeah us white men this white men
are oppressed and I'm like what are you
talking about man when have you ever
come up against a challenge well you
know I heard I heard that that Daryl
tried to get a job and there was a black
woman and he didn't get the job because
of a black woman well it's probably
because she's smarter she's better at
the [__] job she's probably more
qualified than Daryl
Daryl is an idiot he's a dumb [__] he
really is and the reason why he's a dumb
Buck is because he's a white dude he's
been allowed in this country with his
privilege just to Sail by
they have no accountability no no
[__] responsibility just Sail by
based on his privilege that he has given
to him by our the institution of our
society in this democracy
and that is the thing that we must fight
against
yes yes yes I know privilege is great
to all you white hate Watchers out there
who think I'm a race Trader listen
listen just because you give other
people the same privilege you get
doesn't mean you lose your privilege you
stupid [__]
Equity inequality is not a scary thing
and if it is a scary thing you have
white privilege
I don't understand why Marjorie Taylor
green doesn't understand this the reason
why she's standing in front of her cell
phone talking about how white people got
it bad especially white men is because
there is white privilege
oh my God I I can't I can't I can't just
run around being racist anymore I can't
go into a Subway and and tell the people
of color that are working there and call
them the n-word and throw stuff at them
and yell and scream at them and bark
orders at him without someone recording
it and putting it on social media and
showing the world and I'm a white
supremacist racist I can't even do that
anymore what kind of country is this is
that what she's talking about that's
what she's [__] talking about
that's what she's talking about
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty Marjorie and
by the way by the way
equality and Equity to the oppressors
makes them feel oppressed
and that's where the phrase [__] ass
[__] comes in and I think it's highly
highly appropriate in this situation uh
today is Tuesday you know what Tuesday
is it Taco Tuesday all around the world
one of our favorite food days Taco
Tuesday but it's also Texas fall Tuesday
we have Texas Paul here and we're going
to talk about this Russia Ukraine news
with Joe Biden being over in Russia and
in Poland
um I I think he's just coming off the
speech I'm not sure I don't know if he's
done I just seen clips of it I really
honestly I I may go watch the whole
thing today but
um after just a few Clips I I know what
Joe Biden's aim is here after watching
clips of Putin's speech I know exactly
what the administration did by putting
Joe Biden on the ground with president
zielinski in the moment before Putin's
speech it's beautiful
um everyone's wanting to know if we're
going to have a a World War and a
nuclear war not not not not in the near
future not with Joe Biden being the
president of the United States or not
that's for damn sure Putin has totally
totally underestimated Joe Biden and his
his chops for foreign policy and I think
um how he has his thumb on the world's
view now a lot of people are talking
about China this morning China and
Russia and how you know World War
nuclear bombs
um I'm very confident with what has
transpired over the last 48 hours that
we are not we are not closer to a
nuclear where we are further away from
it and the more Putin leans into this
conflict in Ukraine the shorter his
Reign is going to be so it Vladimir
Putin hey hey vladi if you're listening
if you're listening which you probably
wouldn't listen to this I don't think
you speak does he speak English I don't
think he does and he just speaks Russian
you think he would he was KGB like he's
not a dumb guy Putin's not stupid
I mean I mean
I guess it depends on what you define as
stupid but I mean he's not he's not
[__] dumb
he just a little ignorant he's
delusional does he speak English I have
no idea
maybe he refuses to speak English but
Waddy if you if you're listening if
you're listening man man
I would either recommend an ammo
sandwich for lunch or or just giving up
on this hole you're gonna win a Ukraine
thing I I just I'm not sure if you
understand what just happened but what
just happened is the beacon of liberal
Western democracy just got in front of a
microphone and said no [__] no
autocrats only understand one word no no
no and Ukraine will never be a victory
for Russia never
is what Joe Biden the president United
States just said in Poland and the
entirety of NATO and the Western liberal
democracies around the world stand
behind him
you're [__] buddy you and and the fact
that you have to go to China
the fact that you have to go to China
only shows your weakness it only shows
how how clear it is that you are not
going to win in Ukraine and your days
are numbered so my advice I mean this
would be my advice if I was Putin's
advisor I would tell him you should
probably [__] off is what you should I
think that's what you you should [__]
off and not do the whole Ukraine thing
anymore you should really just go back
to riding horses without your shirt on
and you know sending love letters to
Trump it's probably a thing that you
should do and get back to the end troll
on Twitter right I mean we're always
going to have what what what would
Twitter be with all the Russian bot
trolls what would it be I mean would it
even be Twitter anymore Elon I want to
know if we didn't add the Russian bot
trolls would it be Twitter anymore
um I'll wait for a response uh while
we're waiting on the response I want to
tell you and I want to thank you for
supporting the Tony Michaels podcast
sharing liking watching the audience is
growing larger and larger every single
week
and I want to tell you yesterday we had
a goal of getting to 100 on the page on
my patreon and you guys blew it out of
the water we're at 109. I can't even
tell you how excited I am that that you
have that much support for me it is it
made my day yesterday when you guys
slammed through
slammed through that number of 100 so
we're going to set a new goal today here
on the Tony Michaels podcast of 150. why
not let's reach celebration sooner don't
you think so 150 so if you're out there
and if you're considering supporting the
show do it in a lot of different ways
here's how you can do it you can share
this link
you can you can you can subscribe to
YouTube it's it's free just go to the
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube
subscribe for free you can go follow us
on Twitter with all the Russian bot
trolls at Tony Michaels pod you can
download every single episode for free
on Apple Spotify Google absolutely 100
free you can follow me on Twitter for
free at the Tony Michaels Tony Michaels
on Twitch
if you're a prime user if you have
Amazon Prime you can log into twitch
and you get one free subscription
you can give that subscription to me
and that helps out the show it's free to
do that if you were if you are an Amazon
Prime member
but if you can like share just spread
the word tell your friends tell anyone
that you know about this show because
this show is free it doesn't cost you a
nickel to watch or listen to this show
on any platform any device two hours
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
Live on YouTube
and Facebook simulcasting from the Midas
touch Facebook page as a matter of fact
but I want to thank all the patrons out
the members of patreon out there that
got us over 100 thank you so much and I
understand I understand that sometimes
you can't afford the monetary support no
problem you come here you chat every day
this is one of the best audiences one of
the best conversations in the world
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
and it's it's because of you and I want
I want you to get into the chat on
YouTube or on Facebook or on Twitch and
I want you to thank the moderators there
as well they work their asses off
making sure that the hate Watchers
keep just hate watching and get rid of
the trolls the ones that are just here
to troll and say racist [__] and all
kinds of crazy stuff you know the ones
I'm talking about you're in the chat
you're in the chat so thank you very
much for blowing through the goal of 100
let's get to 150. I appreciate all the
support and again this is my job that's
how that's how I make money one more way
I make money is if you go to the the
merch store go to
store.dtonymichaels.com help me out over
there there's a new design surf set
[__] I actually put a pullover
hoodie there will be more merch coming
with the surf set [__] so if
you're waiting on a certain type of
merch like a sticker or something don't
fret it's coming I'll let you know when
it's there just keep checking back at
store.thetonymichaels.com that
store.thetonymichaels.com
boy what an exciting week we have so
much news one other piece of news that I
haven't even got to yet that I'm sure
will work into this week if not today we
got to talk about it
it's Kevin McCarthy giving Tucker
Carlson 40 000 hours
of insurrection footage now a lot of
people are really upset about this
they're really upset but here's
when I heard that this is what was
happening I was like oh this is totally
gonna blow up in their face this is good
I I really honestly I was like this is
going to create hours of me mocking
Tucker Carlson is what it's gonna do
it's listen there's no way Tucker
Carlson isn't going to [__] this up no
[__] way Tucker Carlson is not gonna
[__] this up no way not especially not
after seeing the text messages that
we've seen about the big lie in the 2020
election how he didn't believe any of
that [__] and he thought they were
lunatics anyone that was selling that
garbage
there's no way Tucker doesn't [__] this
up and I'll tell you why later on the
show if we can get to that point uh we
are going to get to it sometime this
week
for show
don't go anywhere don't go anywhere
we're gonna take a quick break when we
come back you know what time it is it is
Texas fall Tuesday stick around we'll be
right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Mega
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble Mega Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
yeah jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
[Music]
[__] Tuesday
oh my God it's freezing it feels like
there's a month worth of news
again an hour and a half oh [__] wow we
got two hours tomorrow that's how it
goes that is how it goes and you know
what Tuesday is I don't even think I
need to tell you what Tuesday is because
everyone's in the comments Texas Fall
Texas Paul Texas Paul Texas Paul
I want to welcome
the one the only Texas ball do the Tony
Michaels podcast Texas ball it's Tuesday
how are you sir wonderful wonderful it's
good to be with you I always I always
love doing this show man I do this is
this is the best show on Earth isn't it
I'm telling you you're killing it I
think so I mean you know I'm a little
biased though but yeah
I agree with you man you do an amazing
job I really I look forward to this all
week long I do I sit there all week you
know what I need to talk about this on
Tony I wonder what Tony Show's going to
be Tuesday and then you know that's why
you you were texting me yeah what are we
going to talk about and I think I text
back text back Russia Russia Russia as
well yeah because that's that's the big
news today
um and I don't I don't know if you've
you've watched any of the clips of
Biden's speech uh the one that stands
out to me of course he there's a few
clips that stand out he was talking
about Finland and Sweden joining NATO uh
which obviously is a huge sign for NATO
that NATO is not the enemy here like
they're not Gathering up Nations to
protect their citizens and their
democracies from an autocrat like Putin
because you know they're the bad guy I
mean if you think democracy is bad I
guess they're the bad guy to Marjorie
Taylor green and Tucker Carlson I guess
they would be the bad guy because they
love democracy they want democracy but
the the one the clip that stands out to
me the most
um is Joe Biden when he talks about
autocrats understanding one word and
that's no no no and there's there's
never going to be a victory in Russia I
think he's sending a signal to China
because that's been the talk that
Putin's gonna try to sink seek help from
China to arm himself
yeah there's been so much behind the
scenes stuff going on you know the right
Wingers are trying to run with the oh
we're going to have a nuclear war thing
because Putin keeps talking about
talking about that that is actually just
a message I mean we don't have any real
diplomacy going on with Russia right now
um that's just a message from Putin that
says look I go down all of my nukes are
up for grab and there's nothing I can do
about it that's not really a threat that
he in no freaking way Putin starts a
nuclear exchange no way I mean it's just
not going to happen he loves his country
and that's one thing you can say about
Putin is he is a patriot he loves Russia
he does not want Russia to be as
smoldering Ash Heap anymore than we want
America to be a smoldering as she
started to fire nuclear weapons they
would be a smoldering ass sheep they
would they would their subjects does not
end well for a lot of people but Russia
is would be at the top of that Ash heap
of not it would take two minutes for the
subs with the Trident missiles to get
their orders
the bird Russian Birds would still be in
the air when they're launching their
retaliation strike it's just that's not
reality the right Wingers are losing
their minds over it that's just a
message from Putin that says hey look I
go down we have instability and there's
a lot of [__] happening in Russia right
now that that really backs that up man
it's getting crazy over there well and
likely
um the uh the likelihood that Putin
actually has a modern nuclear Arsenal is
actually very unlikely like there's a
lot of evidence that shows that his
Arsenal has aged
um it's probably not it's not functional
100 so even if he wanted to have a
strike he doesn't have that much
capability that he would have had 20 30
years ago and yeah and and in that fact
is when he's seeking help from China
because let's be honest here Ukraine had
to seek help from the from the outside
world the outside uh Western liberal
democracy world because they were not
equipped to go against Russia now Putin
thought he was going to take this in
three hours a year ago and here we are a
year from now and Putin has to give a
big speech which Joe Biden [__] all over
of yesterday I mean Amen brother now and
I'll tell you I'll tell you yesterday
um I saw the significance in the in the
meeting with him and zielinski but but I
didn't quite understand it until after I
listened to some of Putin's speech and I
was like holy [__] our spies in Russia
are so much better than the spies here
in the United States because I I bet I
bet they knew almost every single word
that Putin was gonna say before he said
it months ago
um I I think that's that's that's
probably the intelligence that we got
and they acted on yeah there are spies
and our strategists I mean we know we
know what corner Putin's backed into and
we know why China is helping them out
it's not because China wants to end up
in a pissing contest with us that's the
last thing they want China's saying we
need we need Russian not to collapse and
Biden sent a clear message in that
speech today
no matter what happens
Putin goes right well and that's why I
said earlier that I think you know Putin
you know this ends badly for him either
way and he's really in a situation where
he's not going to get out of this
um without you know again eating an ammo
sandwich whether someone feeds it to him
or he eats it himself uh and I I use
that phrase but everyone knows what the
hell I'm talking about I mean this is
how this is how authoritarian murderous
dictators commit war crimes this is how
it ends for them and it's not going to
end well for Putin and the longer he
commits to the atrocities in Ukraine by
invading and killing civilians just for
the sake of taking their Sovereign
democracy as a land grab of it used to
be the used to be Russia
is it it is only it is only making his
Reign smaller and his time as as the
leader of Russia smaller I believe
yeah and in his speech today he was
talking about preserving human rights
and [__] like that when they're I mean
it's just hypocritical as hell I mean
they're just war criminals you know
they're just war criminals I I really
believe over the next little bit you're
gonna see because you know who evgeny
pragosan is the head of the Wagner group
uh explain explain that you sent that to
me and I told you to bring it up today
so explain to the audience what's going
on
well you've if you don't
know the the majority of the the gains
that are going on in Russia right now
have been by the Wagner group because
they're using that Old World War II Uh
Russian Soviet style of just yeeding
people across the field to try to get
there are some estimates that Wagner is
losing a thousand
mercenaries for every 100 yards they
gain and this is the group that is
assaulting Ukraine the Russian group
that is assaulting Ukraine the Wagner
right we've actually had soldiers yeah
we've actually had a battle with them if
if you uh
um you may remember this it's called The
Battle of kasham
um they attacked a Refinery that we were
protecting and they tried to take the
refinery and uh one of the most
hilarious uh I mean it is it's freaking
hilarious Transmissions we ever
intercepted was the commander of the
Wagner group that was you know the
mercenaries attacking our troops they
were there the Russian general was like
how's it going he says I'll tell you how
is how it's going they got two guys up
there with a radio and a coffee pot and
they're calling in air strikes and
they're kicking our ass
oh my God two guys two guys killing an
entire group I mean I mean you know and
this is really what I was talking about
because I want you to get back to this
but this is what I was talking about
with with the reason why Putin is uh
Desperately Seeking China's reprieve in
weaponizing and giving him giving him
weapons and the reason why is because
folks as the Western World gives
ukraines more and more modern weapons
Putin's [__] he is completely [__]
the Wagner group is [__] they're all
[__] and and you you're seeing a break
in the Wagner group is that is that
really okay yeah okay what is that I
understand to understand you just got to
learn a little bit of how because pagos
and Putin used to be tight really tight
in the 80s pregos and went to prison
okay if it's been about 12 years in a
Russian prison comes out starts a hot
dog cart company not bullshitting that's
how he could start a hot dog cart
company oh my God Saves his money he is
he's a freaking criminal but he's a
criminal with a with a work ethic man
this guy is dangerous
takes the money from the hot dog cart
company opens a really Swanky restaurant
still open today gets great reviews it's
called the old custom house in St
Petersburg okay and you got an at the
time St Petersburg had just been renamed
St Petersburg
um and all the [__] was fluid in Russia
so what he's doing he opens this
restaurant
you know he's a criminal he knows he
knows how to schmooze people so he's all
the local uh officials love this place
because pergos and treats him like kings
and he becomes really tight with the
deputy mayor of Saint Petersburg guy by
the name of Vladimir Putin
I've heard of him I've heard of him yeah
so as Putin's star Rises
he takes progozin with them all of a
sudden per goes and starts getting
government contracts and yada yada and
eventually it turns into Putin needs
somebody to do dirty work per goes and
says I'll do that so what he means is
when he goes in to negotiate in Africa
let's say uh you know over oil fields or
whatnot he's like this is my deal take
it or leave it but you really want to
take it if there's any hesitation
pragosan's people showed up the Wagner
group and started killing people
so they were originally real Russian
military ex-military that he hired think
about Blackwater you know Eric Prince
hiring all the ex-military out of Iraq
and then sending them back into Iraq you
know what I'm saying he created that
kind of company equivalent to something
like Blackwater to begin with
when Ukraine went South pagosan said hey
man I got this i got this and
to conscript
criminals
so I mean they'd be walking down the
street and it was like somebody throw a
cigarette out hey you broke the law put
a pistol to his head and said
you want to join
and then they would drag him off to a
Wagner facility
give them a couple days worth of
training and next thing you know they're
in Ukraine
you know and they they give them orders
run across that field to that spot dig a
hole and hold it and if they didn't
they'd shoot them right there in fact
the the symbol for the Wagner group is
now a sledgehammer because they were
putting videos up on telegram of anybody
that didn't want to go they would tape
their head to a block
on the wall and then they would take
that sledgehammer and crack their head
open
oh wow you kill him yeah it sounds like
a Mobsters or something right this is
the this is the kind of guy he's a he's
a he's a psychopath he goes into the
psychopath but he was Putin psychopath
uh you know well
problem is he developed a mouth
okay there's a guy his name's Sergey
shogu he is the equivalent of Lloyd
Austin here the Secretary of Defense
okay he's their minister of defense
and um another guy my name is Valeria
guerrazimov he is a much beloved General
in the Russian army he is our equivalent
of Mark Mark mallick Mark milley
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
per goes and starts talking [__] about
these two because he's like I can't get
the ammunition I need he's getting free
ammunition free rides free weapons
you know he he's not a genius building
this business the Russian military
supporting him well the Russian military
said hey we're there fighting too and
we're short on on ammo I don't give a
[__] about your
your conscripts I don't give a [__]
about your mercenaries and they start
holding ammunition back
Pro goes and runs his mouth about it
and he attacks imagine somebody
attacking Lloyd Austin and attacking
Mark milley and calling them traitors
here in the United States imagine if
Eric Prince from Blackwater did that on
the news
held a press conference and called Lloyd
Austin and you know that's the
equivalent of what happened
Putin yanked to Shane took his ability
he cannot conscript criminals anymore
and 80 percent of his Force are
criminals
pregos and sees the writing on the wall
because Putin has now put uh grazimov in
charge
of Ukraine for this spring offensive
grasimov is a real General this is this
guy's the real deal he believes in the
military he's holding all his resources
all his all his ammunition all his
logistical resources for the military
pergos and sees himself being taken off
the field
taken off the board this is Pagosa is
the the Wagner group leader the Wagner
group guy yeah
there's no soft Landing for that
because now he's not Putin's guy anymore
dick he's just any old lunatic now right
right and and pragos and sees the
writing on the wall so the last two days
pragosan
threw the gauntlet down he's walked
outside the headquarters of Wagner group
in St Petersburg Russia and given press
conferences two days in a row where he
calls shoigu and garasimov traitors and
says that Russia's Russia's betrayed him
and his soldiers in Ukraine
and he's he just said it's on and if
something else that's really weird
that's happened you know you know these
guys keep yeeting themselves at Windows
you know
[__] like that like uh uh right right uh
gave Sanchez in the background agreeing
eh I want to bring him in dude Avalanche
off
went went flying off the the roof of a
building
you know well some
people think they can fly you know or
some people think when they've toss
people off buildings they might be able
to fly I don't know who knows a couple
of there's one that's not like the
others okay you had like Vadim boyko he
was a colonel
um he committed suicide by shooting
himself five times
okay yeah I mean I mean if you're gonna
do it if you're gonna do it you might as
well you might as well make sure you're
dead you know what I mean yeah you might
as well shoot yourself five times yeah
this one's the chest in the chest yeah
well you're like to the temple and then
the other four went to the chest right
right well he was he was murdered
because he didn't suck a bullet himself
he was the he's one of the guys that
failed in the logistics in Ukraine okay
he got he got demoted and taken off the
field was teaching and didn't kill
himself so they did it for him then he
had another guy by the name of Vladimir
Makarov he was second in command he went
home and he did it he put a hunting
rifle in his mouth and he sucked a
bullet wow he would rather have won he
would rather have one than five you know
maybe his fan his family keeps his house
in [__] if he does that right the other
one's different though and I know you've
heard about this five days ago wait a
second hold that thought hold that
thought did you just say if he shoots
himself his family keeps the house but
if they end up coming after him they
take the [__] house too well yeah is
that like some kind of law
it's also typical like uh like if
there's someone in a gang right any type
of gang right and they're like look we
need a Fall Guy and the Fall Guy doesn't
play ball right then they go okay great
we're gonna make sure that nobody
protects your family and we're going
after him however if you take the fall
and you're innocent for sure uh and and
you say I'm guilty and I'm was the one
who committed this crime or whatever
then they will say great your family's
taking care of your wife your kids don't
worry about it this is this is exactly
what Makarov did exactly he said it was
my fault my failure in Ukraine
and then you know yeah ate enamel
sandwich
right right he was a 72 year old man he
was old anyways he just was loyal to the
end yeah
the one that's different and I know
you've heard about this was the woman
Marina yankina
she was Putin's gal in the defense
Ministry she's the one that got the
funding for Ukraine
she was doing her job she was not a
failure that's one thing you can say
about Russia is they still have money to
spend to keep this war going and it was
Marina yukina yankina that did that
she was not on the outs with Putin she
just flew out a 16th floor apartment
Window yeah
and she was Putin's gal
I'm speculating here she did she make it
did she make it no no no
I didn't know she grew I have no idea I
don't know she had all kinds of all
kinds of things that AI are doing these
days I didn't know if you know she grew
a pair of wings and blue I had no idea
but think about that all the rest of
them all the rest of them you had POV
lantov he was talking [__] about Putin
he was a local politician well liked he
was a threat
this guy eats himself out a window in
India you know what I mean
but this woman is different
and I really really am I'm speculating
here
really pissed people off I think that
was pragosan I do I think that was I
think that
the the fight has started so you're so
you're thinking what you're thinking is
that there is a that Putin's now at war
with with a Russian mobster basically
it's all behind the scenes yeah they are
jockeying because what you've got like
is uh you've heard a gas problem before
the largest oil company in Russia
Biden blew up their pipeline he won't
admit it but he blew up their pipeline
you know
the guy that runs out Alexi Miller was
just given permission he's a Putin
loyalty loyalist was just given
permission
to do what pragosan was doing he's
raising a private Army
um
uh Rams on uh kadiroff you remember
hearing about chechnya the Butcher of
chechnya the guy that ended up being
appointed in a brutal guy extreme Putin
loyalist he's been given permission to
raise his own private Army
they're warlording up and what Putin's
doing is trying to make sure this isn't
like when the Soviet Union collapsed if
he goes out the door
these guys everything's not you know you
don't have like Oleg deripaska just you
know who's now the world's aluminum
magnet walking in with 40 guys and
saying I own this now and that's what
he's trying to avoid and then on top of
that he's sending that message to Joe
Biden saying you know if you keep
putting pressure on me this goes bad for
you
because these [__] aren't sane and
and he's right there there's freaking
Psychopaths man
so China's like please let us just prop
them up please let us just prop Russia
up
and of course we can't do that we can't
say okay go ahead so you know right well
yeah I mean it's kind of disingenuous
when you're like you know we want to
defend democracy around the world so
we're going to provide weapons of
Ukraine and oh by the way China wink go
ahead give him the weapon so we can let
him find it out I mean this is really
this is really and and again I I want to
show you this video because I think this
is um this is the clip that everyone
needs to grab a hold of because and I
haven't watched the whole speech but
this basically sends the message to
Putin and China I believe and really the
rest of the world on uh what the United
States policy is on this now and as long
as Joe Biden is the president which will
be uh until 2028
um is is what he'll be president till so
here is here's his stance on autocrats
across Europe
's types of the autocrac
cannot be appeased they must be opposed
autocrats only understand one word no
no no no
you will not take my country
no you will not take my freedom no you
will not take my future
all right what I said last year in the
same place
a dictator
can I rebuilding an Empire will never be
able to ease the people's love of
Liberty
brutality
will never grind down the will of the
free
Ukraine
Ukraine will never be a victory for
Russia never
so there's the president of the United
States the leader of the Free World and
liberal democracy around the Free World
it is refreshing that um we have a
present that stands with freedom and
liberty not just here but uh to all
those who want and will fight for it
unlike the last guy and the the [__]
Republican uh eventual nominee Donald
Trump
um who definitely loves authoritarianism
he loves autocrats he loves dictators he
loves war criminals uh as well because
he wants to be one that is why he is the
way he is but it is great to see that
our Democracy stand strong with the rest
of the democracies around the world for
Liberty and freedom as the president
United States from Poland repeats again
to all the autocrats no no no no I think
it sends a great message and also him
going to Ukraine with the president of
Ukraine zielinski especially the video
where the air raid sirens are going off
um is a beautiful not only is it a
beautiful message to send around the
world that we're not afraid and we're
not going to cower to your
authoritarianism in your war crimes but
also after Putin's speech and now this
speech it is clear to me it is very
clear to me that we have way better
spies in Russia than they even dream of
having in this country
um because this was I I don't believe
that this happened just so happened this
way this was exactly planned by the
administration by the president United
States and his team to make sure that
this is the image that everyone has
because Putin not only looks short he
looks very small at this point
oh yeah
what I was going to say is yeah I mean
the ability to maneuver I mean like
obviously like everything is is always
the visual right like how do you sell
this idea and how do you sell this
policy and I think for Joe Biden to walk
in you know [__] big balls into a war
zone when we know that the complete
opposite of of of that image is Donald
Trump tear gassing protesters in front
of a church so he could go take a photo
with an upside down Bible right we know
that he was hiding in the bunker despite
the fact he's like I wasn't hiding in
the bunker that's all fake news this and
that even though we have multiple
reports from people inside the cabinet
and those adjacent we're like yeah he
was hunkered down in a bunker the dude
hunkered down in a bunker while people
were outside protesting they couldn't
get anywhere near the the white house
but he decided
the real threat the real threat were
these protesters who were chanting you
know black lives matter and uh Sanchez
Justice Gabe Sanchez the truth is they
are a threat they are a threat to to his
to his narrative and his messaging and
his fraud it is a threat right peaceful
protest and democracy is the thing they
fear the most and watch this I I don't
know
honestly I don't know if the White House
listens to the show I have no [__]
clue I don't know who listens to the
show to be quite honest out there I know
you do
um but this this this clip right here
and I haven't seen it I've just read the
transcript of it here but I'm gonna show
it to you see if you've if you've heard
this messaging before from somebody just
just listen
he thought autocrats like himself were
tough
and leaders of democracy were soft
and then he met the Iron Will of America
in the Nations everywhere that refused
to accept the world governed by fear and
force
he found himself at war with a nation
led by a man whose courage would be
forged in Fire and steel president
zielinski
um I say all the time and I don't know
if anyone's catching this I say all the
time liberalism is not it's not weakness
it is strength and I believe that is
what the president United States is
saying in that very statement so again I
don't know if the White House is
listening but if you are you're doing a
damn bang-up job
um of listening to what the hell I'm
saying and projecting it around the
world so again I don't know if they're
doing that but you know I might be
patting myself on the back a little too
soon there but I I will say I will say
the audience knows that I say that all
the time Texas Paul that liberalism is
not weakness liberalism is the position
of strength all around the world that is
the whole point of Freedom you are never
going to convince an entire group of
people that they should not fight to the
death for their Liberty and their
freedom you're just not gonna do it why
don't these [__] learn this why Texas
Paul why haven't they learned this
you got me man I really do I really
don't know the answer to that question I
just I yeah
ah I don't understand why
well I guess I do understand grazimov
the guy that's in charge of Ukraine now
he made the original plan and 98 it
worked if it hadn't been for the balls
of the Ukrainian people that said
all right let's throw down let's do it
we're not we're not you know
if if they had been right about
zielinski saying okay don't hurt my
people
I'll leave I'll go into Exile you know
if that had happened grandson I was
playing would have worked in Ukraine
they'd had it in three days because
militarily they were on the edge of Kiev
I mean quickly they were but they
couldn't sustain it because the Russian
military has just been so corrupt lately
I mean the last few decades it's just
just horribly corrupt but yeah I I don't
get it I really don't get it Tony I
don't understand why why would you think
that somebody's going to let you just
walk into your country
and and
I love that big balls yeah so so Regina
so Regina points out here because
everyone knows that I hate the messaging
of BBB the build back better that was so
stupid the messaging was horrible they
tried to make it an infrastructure bill
when they should have made it an
education bill which we're going to talk
about education here in a little bit
um and and education police to be
specific but Regina says BBB is no
longer build back better and now means
Big Balls biting Big Balls biting I mean
Sanchez the speech that he gave was Big
Dick Energy yeah There Was You know
despite what Kerry Lake may say that was
actual bde you know and into the
question earlier you know like why do
they keep doing this I think it you know
it's it's that it's that moment of you
know doing the same thing and expecting
a different outcome right and we've
talked about this on the show before and
we talk about how you know fascists and
dictators there's no
there's no uh new Innovative strategy to
being a dictator or fascist right you're
authoritarian that's there's only one
way out right and that's to say that my
way is the only way
and your your way doesn't matter your
voice doesn't matter
there's nothing inventive there's
nothing Innovative there's nothing
creative about that it's literally the
same Playbook we've seen it that has
happened years and years over time it
has cycled through when you know people
doubt democracy or want to uh weaken
democracy then there's a group that says
hey well the better option here is if
only one person gets to determine what
everyone else does right and then after
a while you say oh this is oppression
and I I want to be free and I want to
you know see who I want to see talk
about what I want to talk about you know
love who I want to love and we're seeing
that cycle happen now where we're
getting you know this challenge of a
small group of people who want to
control uh the majority of what people
do right whether it's Education Health
Care uh uh the lgbtq community and their
rights like who you can marry who you
can see who you can talk to I mean I'm
sure at some point you know we've heard
it before from other people like oh you
can't speak that you got to speak
American and you're like
that's [__] dumb but at the end of
the day I really think that's what it is
dumber than me saying that's dumber than
me saying salsa right no it really is it
really is well like I'm just trying to
get the tech talks that the taco Tuesday
taco right no no makes sense and I think
you know uh like any taco right it's not
it's not fine with just one type of
thing right you you take it it takes
diversity and eclectic mix cilantro
onions salsa whatever your meat or not
meat product is the tortilla whether
it's flower corn it all comes in
together and makes this this harmony
okay right and this Melting Pot and
tacos for democracy tacos for democracy
oh my God wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait we
haven't got the PAB [__] ass [__] 45
shirts out yet but I just I just have a
new merch idea everyone wait don't pause
tacos
for democracy tell me what you think in
the comments I mean cfd let's do it but
what I will say is you know is like a
taco like a good taco like an authentic
Street taco
it's it's made with love right and care
right it's made with all of these simple
ingredients but they all come together
to make this very harmonious
uh diversity of delicious goodness is
that what you're saying and and anyone
Republican party fascists uh dictators
uh authoritarian groups whatever you
might say they are the ones who want to
strip away rights and take this they
want to make it the [__] blandest
thing ever they would say oh meat on a
piece of Wonder Bread that's it right
right
bologna I'm not knocking fried bologna
but nothing else other than just the
fried bologna so what you're saying is
Putin despises tacos is what you're
saying is that what you're saying I I
don't know I'm hearing multiple multiple
times I've heard you know from other
people allegedly many people are saying
right Putin doesn't like tacos Putin
does not like the diversity of tacos
well and [__] [__] that Cracker yeah go
ahead forgive me Tony I misunderstood
your question there you're asking why
the Republicans keep doing this [__]
what's that that oh yeah Taco talk I'm
hungry now sorry you're asking where the
Republicans didn't keep doing this [__]
they live in a [__] echo echo chamber
and they're paid to it's you know like
right now DeSantis is I'm about to
destroy Ron DeSantis you know he's Mr
I'm I'm the outsider I'm the guy that's
that's fighting The Establishment well
he's taking tons of freaking money from
the Manhattan Institute in in in the
form of support and propaganda all that
CRT [__] and the anti-woke [__]
all comes out of the Manhattan Institute
a guy by the name Christopher Ruffo
um and that's all they hear that's all
they hear so they think it's a good idea
and they get that feedback out of that
that bubble that feedback loop and they
don't understand that the one thing the
one thing DeSantis had going for him was
that Florida schools were rated
number one in the country
they were before he did all this [__]
they were rated number one in the
country he had that to run on
any [__] destroyed them
course of course he did he did
everything he was in that feedback loop
and he went with the CRT [__] and
the anti-woke [__] and he's driving
teachers out of Florida in droves
teachers are quitting before retirement
you're talking about halfway to
retirement they're quitting wait wait
Texas Paul you're making the assumption
that it is important to have good
teachers so kids can get educated this
is this is way way are you some kind of
mother woker or something the thing that
you need good teachers to have children
educated decent are you what what are
you up your rocker which brings me which
brings me
to a part that I want to get to I was
going to skip around but I'm going to
skip back here since we're talking about
Florida men and Florida man and I do
have a little fun fact for people yeah
go ahead Ron DeSantis so you know how
Ron DeSantis was in the Navy right and
everyone's like oh you know he's a
military man and all this [__] [__]
right you know what he you know what his
job was in the military what was what
did he do he was an assistant your
analysis coordinator what what what's a
urinalysis it's the one who tests the
drugs right it's a drug screen wait wait
wait wait he's the P guy he held the
p-cups yeah he held the p-cups who was a
physical fitness coordinator a
recruiting officer and an assistant wait
wait back up you said physical what
Fitness wait wait are you are we talking
about the the same Rhonda Santos the guy
are you saying that fat slob was some
kind of you kidding me I'm not kidding
you you know I actually believe that
Rhonda santis got fatter to look more
like Trump what do you think I think so
I mean
has never had an original thought in his
life
everything he's talking about with his
anti-woke stuff and the CRT stuff comes
straight out of the Manhattan Institute
uh it's an old school think tanks
started by Bill Casey the CIA director
uh that's whose most famous quote is
when uh everybody in America I'm
paraphrasing here when everybody in
America believes falsehoods our
misinformation campaign will be complete
I mean that's one of his most famous
quotes Okay this guy's Institute
is is funneling old school Blue Blood
you know how the old school Republicans
want to destroy schools that's what's so
hilarious about this is he had this
thing he could have run on number one
schools in the country
but the Manhattan Institute funnels all
of this [__] CRT [__] his way and
he's destroying his own schools
for the Blue Bloods in Manhattan
that are funding all of this propaganda
he's he thinks the propaganda is going
to carry him carry him he he thinks that
he's going to survive the ratings next
year when Florida schools hit the trash
because you know that veteran program
that they had
about we're gonna let veterans teach you
don't need a degree yeah yeah how'd that
work yeah yeah they've got seven
teachers out of that damn seven they're
short
they're short over 5 000 teachers and
teachers are quitting every day because
I don't know the government says they're
going to charge them with Governor says
[__] [__] felonies if you say the
wrong thing okay I think I figured it
out I think I figured it out all right
with our conversation here I think I
figured out why Rhonda Santos is such a
[__] bonehead I think when he was in
the military and maybe we should take it
easy on him here I think maybe he he got
way too much exposure to urine fumes and
that killed off all his [__] brain
cells here I think that's what happened
to Rhonda that's a possibility I mean
you know I mean keep in mind he wasn't
he wasn't the your analysis coordinator
he was the assistant so he was a
urinalysis of course the urine your
analysis yeah
he was actually sniffing the the [__]
piss he was yeah he was the one yeah he
was he was the one who made a lot of
broccoli today yeah I mean asparagus
asparagus yeah there you go well
whatever whatever you know someone else
who loves urine who's probably smoked a
lot of brain cells getting pissed on
this guy oh yeah this guy this guy loves
golden showers um speaking of that did
you know I think it's being reported
right now uh in the public that Michael
Cohen is sitting with Alan Bragg for the
Third time it's being reported third
time is today so um if you're out there
and you like the to watch Michael Cohen
talk about his meetings with Alan Bragg
I'm sure we're going to get a dose of
that here soon I'm just just saying you
know P tapes Trump Stormy Daniels porn
star I just kind of brought Michael
Cohen up in my mind that he's he's um
he's giving evidence Alan Bragg about
this guy's crimes but this guy
um over was this released last night
Gabe Sanchez this video this is a clip
of it this came out the the statue
education police yeah this one was uh 19
hours 20 hours ago so this this is this
is
because We've joked about it before but
I Liz Harrington if you're listening
um you've really you've really done a
bang-up job changing these videos with
mine and Gabe Sanchez's um little
adjustments that we told you to make
you've really done a bang-up job like
visually but the scripts oh my God the
scripts keep going with them because
they're going to be gold next year in
the general election they are going to
be [__] gold in the general election
well you know what you know what he's
calling all of these now what is what is
he calling he's he's got a name for him
now now they've got a theme they're not
just like General like here's a video of
me talking about something now these are
all part of this agenda 47.
that means that means he is admitting
that he lost in 2020. well I mean you
have to I mean he when he announced that
he was running again right that was the
first time but now he is officially
saying he's the 47th president right
yeah I mean even though his digital
trading cards did have 47 on there so
you know I think he's
he's been subtly doing it but now he's
got this agenda 47 thing so you'll be
seeing more things under this like
umbrella of I'm gonna reduce crime Law
and Order this and that education all
under agenda 47. well it's not
surprising and the other thing to Texas
Paul that I want to go back to with the
Santos because I believe this video
is actually him getting out ahead of
DeSantis like oh you're gonna out Hitler
me I don't think so [__] you can only
do this type of stuff in Florida I'm the
fake president of the United States and
I'll do it all around the country listen
this this is so funny it is like an old
dude on the porch and yelling at
children get off my lawn you know my
this this is what I thought of when I
[__] heard this listen well and the
leftist Takeover of school discipline
and Juvenile Justice many of these
carjackers and criminals are 13 14 and
15 years old what the [__] who who are
these 13 14 year old carjackers what the
[__] is he talking about I have no idea
well you know something else I just
noticed something else I just noticed
and I had to go to truth social to
confirm this yeah
see his face right now yeah there's a
lighter glow and a circle that's around
his face it goes down to about like
where halfway of a shoulder collarbone
on each side and above and around you'll
notice that there's a light there's a
light shading around and also where the
candles are it gets a little darker I
had to confirm this I went to uh true
social
it looks like now they are doing
additional Lighting on him in post
because his face either looks too dark
or too creepy or too I don't know what
but I can tell you for a fact if you
went to truth social right now and
looked it up you would see it's even
more clear because it's straight from
the rumble uh video
but that's what I mean you know they're
color correcting they're making them
shorter they're giving them new intro
slides I mean they're really they're not
putting it they're not letting them
ramble on either no no they're cutting
them off they're cutting them off
because we told Liz we told Liz hey Liz
don't let him ramble Jesus Christ okay
looks like a lunatic when he [__] I
mean really honestly if you want if you
want Adolf Hitler 2.0 to take over here
in this in this country what you're
gonna have to do is stop him from
talking because I mean what was the one
that we listened to a couple weeks ago
where he just went off and talked about
Chinese people oh yeah he just started
being like he was just like racist
racist racist racist racism oh yeah and
by the way more peppered rates honestly
might have been education related I
completely forget right now but it was
weird it was like he mentioned Chinese
people and like went off in this quick
tangent and then it was clear that they
cut him off and went to some other take
right back to like the front face
because they cut more they actually left
in part of the racism and they cut there
was probably five minutes of it and they
cut it out but let's let's listen to the
last part of this here the get off my
lawn video here
I will order the education and Justice
departments to overhaul Federal
standards on disciplining minors so when
troubled youth are out and trolled
they're out on the streets and they're
going wild
we will stop it the consequences are
Swift certain and strong and they will
know that what the [__] does the
education department have to do with
children going trolling watch
out go on a wild I have no idea I mean
unless what is this these people with
kids man I mean you've got DeSantis you
know wanting to play Nazi dictator and
and having just volunteers you know your
local your local righty tidy out there
going through your kids backpacks and
charging them with crimes if they've got
books that that are banned and [__] like
that and then you got freaking Trump
here running his damn mouth about oh we
got those kids in prison I mean what the
[__] is wrong with these people I
actually I actually I think I know what
he's talking about okay he's complaining
about these kids whileing out right
being all crazy and all this and
hyperactive voting for democrats for
Democrats causing destruction at 14 15.
I I I strongly believe
that in Trump's department or lack of
Education Department uh
is what he's looking for
is he wants to bring back
uh he wants to bring in like corporal
punishment inside the school he wants to
punish children for acting out
and because he's saying like if because
I think that's a connection here he's
saying that children who are 13 14 are
are acting crazy they're stealing cars
they're committing crimes all stuff and
it links all the way back to school so
basically what he wants is he wants
teachers to be the ones to enforce
violence or
punishment or correction or whatever you
want to call it on to these kids so
they're not doing those things out on
the street well you know what I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm Gonna Stand by that now
and say that that is what Trump is
actually advocating for he's advocating
for hitting a kid in school to correct
them from being bad outside well Santa's
go ahead go ahead text Paul do Santa's
just doing the same thing have you heard
what they've done about tracking periods
in Florida yeah
yeah you know in the state of Texas
you're not talking about you're not
talking about punctuation you're talking
no I'm not I'm talking about women
teenage girls periods
in when you do a physical okay in
several States across the country it's
it's not crazy that they ask hey when
did you have your last period this that
and the other it used to not be tied to
this [__] craziness it was just a
health thing like okay are you healthy
are you having I want to clarify you're
talking about sports physicals that
children have sports physicals to
participate in sports
which is a normal thing it's been normal
for a long time to make sure that a
physician says a child is physically
capable of participating in this sport I
mean it makes and in Florida now they're
trying to say you have to keep that
information and track these girls
periods because we may need that later
in case somebody says they got pregnant
we'll have you know evidence to
prosecute them if they in their
pregnancy because you know all these
crazy ass righties are wanting to
process if you leave the state and go to
another state they want to charge you
for a crime and they want to charge you
and they want to make that a crime
they're going to prosecute people that
did things in other states which is just
insane
but the the board that regulates this
says we can't do that
in Florida they did they gave they
pushed back said we can't do that we you
know that's crazy we're not going to
track all this that you're asking us to
track
he fired them all well yeah because yeah
because they were like winning his own
yeah well they were like whoa whoa whoa
you're obsessed with genitalia that's
not gonna work and then and and he and
he made sure to get people that were
obsessed with genitalia for him
yeah exactly he's putting the religious
crazies in on in in in in the board that
regulates this and appointing all his
people and and what I'm saying is
DeSantis is just as bad as Trump about
just mouth diarrhea
I mean there's no thought to this at all
he just thinks that everything he says
they're going to eat it up and love it
and let them let them talk because
sure he keeps a large number of his
people when he does [__] like this
they're they don't care what abuse has
happened they're all in with fascism and
[__]
but he loses enough
that we kick their ass
and that's that's what we need to keep
asking these questions keep punching
that punching them right in the nose man
make them answer these questions because
like I said DeSantis just after being
told we can't do this
you know said watch me fired everybody
and put religious nuts in and now
they're going to attract girls periods
in Florida
for the purpose of having that
information to hand over to
investigators if somebody goes and
actually has an abortion well I mean
I've heard a lot of women
post on social media and I I don't know
anything about this so is and the reason
why I'm I'm ignorant of this but they
say that there is uh apps that are
designed to track your period and your
cycle and to not use those [__] apps
like they're like delete those [__]
apps do not use those factors yeah so
that's that's what happened after Roe v
Wade was overturned and the fear was
that people who typically use this as
their own kind of you know
schedule to know when they should take
uh medication or when they should take
you know birth control or or just on
just knowing where they are because
obviously life is crazy and you know you
just want to stay on top of things right
and it it should it's not something
that's totally outside the realm I mean
you know whether you're taking physical
birth control pills or you have it on a
calendar right like that's it's just the
app is in an attempt to you know make
your life I guess a little bit easier
right but then the downside here is that
these companies own this private data on
you and they could then go to the I mean
I don't know what control the government
or the state local government has to say
like all right you
this company maybe they're incorporating
that state or something but that's very
much what they're trying to do and
they're like look we are
trying to get control of this stuff
because we want to know
who is taking this this uh uh this birth
control who is taking uh this
contraception right so we know exactly
who to come after and who to you know
kick down their door and arrest them
because I mean that's the ultimately the
world that they're trying to create here
right it's a hand yeah these Nazi
bastards are trying to get around HIPAA
that that's exactly what they're doing
that's why they want to track periods in
schools because that's not protected by
HIPAA
you know the the Supreme Court has said
they can ask
you know and so they've already got the
information it's it's not protected by
HIPAA they don't need you know hospitals
doctors your gynecologists can refuse to
hand over it it's just established
federal law they can refuse to hand over
the infra in fact they have to refuse
this is all it is is Nazi bastards
trying to get around so they can get
into your personal [__]
well speaking of Nazi batser bastards I
got a lot of other [__] ass [__] to
get to here today so I would love to
still stoke the uh desantos Trump Civil
War but there's another person who is um
talking about Civil War here this looks
like a carry Lake filter this this
freezing yeah
it's Gotta clear off the Vaseline right
I guess so I I didn't notice that until
just now this is uh Marjorie hoodfoot
green otherwise known as the petty Yeti
and this morning I gave her a new um
handle called the [__] ass pipe bombing
[__]
um but she's whining in this video
Patriot take said this video and then
I'm gonna go to her comments about the
Civil War and World War III and and just
nonsense
um but this this oh oh this video here
it is just a gym let's listen I'm gonna
stand up for white males here the most
mystery group she's
oh my God let me tell you something
about the marginalized group of white
men holy [__] okay I I was gonna find a
way how I could bring this story up but
after we play this video I have a little
bit of my own story
of this white woman that I experienced
on the plane oh coming back to L.A
yesterday okay does does she look like
this was she wearing a a black American
but she had the it looked like she had
aged because of hate you know okay well
I hate does age you pretty bad let's
let's listen to this hateful aged uh
little troglodyte people and the United
States today are white males they are
blamed for everything they're the
scapegoat good everything bad in America
is because of white men that's what
you're told that's what the media I I
want a clip just that part everything in
this country is bad is because of white
men just clip that part and just make
that go viral let's get I mean there
yeah well no no go ahead go ahead no I
was just gonna say
oh no I was gonna say unrelated there
was a there was a good clip of uh George
Santos from his interview with uh here's
Morgan oh we're gonna get to that [__]
and he goes I'm a terrible liar and I
was like that's it that's right that's
right there uh hey Justin T brown Justin
t Brown does a good job with these
videos if you're listening take this
clip and make it something different
something more beautiful and I'll play
this [__] let's keep going yeah once so
tell you that's what the that's what the
Democrats want to tell you they want to
blame everything on white men because
white men are bad and white men are
racist and white men want to hold
everybody down they just want to be
successful themselves no just just the
racist ones just the racist ones it's
just the racist ones that people don't
like because they're racist I don't know
maybe it's just me no it's not fair
that's not fair to my father that's not
fair to my brother that's not fair
they're all racist they're all racist
they're all racist and keep in mind this
video was made before she got her
Divorced with her ex-husband now so he
was also racist too and her father and
her brother
because we know from this CL there's a
clip in this video where she talks about
lazy black people in this video this is
from that same this from that same just
unfiltered just release of these
brilliant Thoughts by Margaret Taylor
green when really it's just I'm a
[__] racist and I'm a terrible human
being right well here's the re this
video and these videos that she made
because I think this is before she
became a member of Congress yeah this is
like during her space laser days when
she really thought I mean those days are
still here well right well he just says
that she doesn't
she went to the Holocaust Museum she was
just which is you would think for
someone who's anti-semitic that's like
the perfect place you would send someone
right you're not going to educate
someone you're going to get someone who
is anti-Semitic to walk into the
Holocaust Museum and say oh this is
actually pretty nice here that is people
like that do not learn lessons they walk
through that place all [__] Giddy and
she is no different let's continue and
that's not fair to my son it is not all
the races too that white men are treated
that way you want to know why because
it's not true this is that is not true
there's so many good white men okay okay
there are good white men out there I'm
talking to two writers
constant Victory I mean Miracles man I
mean five black officers all we do is
say who did what wrong and this [__]
has to find a way to be a [__] victim
in the middle of it I mean
[__] I mean yeah but that's that's
what we do here is to show these people
who you know what I think um is the
moral of the story here there is no way
that Marjorie Taylor green can run on
the ticket with Donald Trump no [__]
way no way in hell not gonna happen it's
gonna be Carrie Lake for sure 100 for
sure it's going to be I mean she's
spending a lot more time in Mar-A-Lago
than margins hit the green so well you
know Margaret Taylor green was bitching
on her on her [__] cast or whatever the
hell she calls it um she was saying I
have to spend so much time here and
watch I can't even go home I can't even
go to Mar-A-Lago I know I can't even go
to Mar-A-Lago to get on my knees and
well she's like I made more money than
before I was congresswoman I don't find
joy and I don't enjoy this job I don't
get to spend time with my family look
dog uh I don't need I don't feel like I
have to spell it out for you but if you
don't enjoy the fact that you're not
getting paid as much money then you
don't you can't spend time with your
family and that it's not fun or
enjoyable then [__] resign
and she's so [__] stupid in the [__]
that she says she's like oh blue States
and red States need a divorce you're in
a [__] Blue State you idiot
Georgia is now a blue State you dumbass
I mean she's so [__] stupid well
let's continue the stupidity okay yeah
there's been some yucky ones yeah
and guess what there's [__] of every
color look look there's an [__] right
here on screen with us
there's [__] out there of course
they're awesome yeah they committed uh
just [__] mass shootings there's some
yucky ones that's how we're going to
represent that group okay I got you okay
they're yucky the people that
assassinated dragged people from their
cars shot people you know kneeled on
people's necks like oh those are those
are just yucky ones guys right they're
not everyone they're not yet you know
right the [__] out of here there are
some rotten people to the core of every
single color and every single race there
it is but it doesn't mean I'm not racist
but why you went over this last week I'm
not racist but and I put it in a clip
I'm not racist but I just I just don't
like black people like what what what I
don't think you understand what the word
of racism means Marge I think you get it
well you know she's pretty limited
white men in this country are good
people and they do good things every
single day
and they are not against anyone
not against black people they are not
against Mexicans they are not against
Asians they are not is she trying to
describe what woke is to us here I think
so I think that she's like the Injustice
that happens inside there is a group of
white people that aren't [__] and
they they they don't they really they
want equality and Equity that's right
and they're they're wokers she's going
after they're called Democrats
oh my God yeah that that fool uh well I
got more um yeah nonsense so let me let
me quickly tell you so I'm on a plane
yesterday and there's this woman that's
sitting the road behind me and she's
having a very very loud conversation
where she's like you know I'm doing this
exercise I'm going outside I'm not
clinically depressed and I was like oh
my god well I don't know what's going on
over here so I kind of zone out
then as the planes taking officer begins
to have a conversation with this guy
that she clearly doesn't know so it's a
woman This Guy's daughter in the middle
seat and the guy that's on the aisle
seat and the reason I stopped my music
and I caught this line clearly she goes
uh so I don't mean to I don't you know I
don't mean a pry but who did you vote
for
which is like a that's a big who would
you say this to this this guy that's
sitting in the aisle seat right so keep
in mind like if you're having a
conversation with someone especially
someone you do not know and you're on a
plane for the next how many of our hours
and the first question you ask this
person is hey who would you vote for
that's not probably gonna be a good
that's never a good like let's break the
ice kind of question right so they start
talking and you know the guy's like Oh
I'm a moderate but more like a Centrist
but he wouldn't say who he voted for so
he me he means he means he hates Trump
no it means I think I think most most of
the time that's the around here when
they're like well because they know
people know I'm a liberal right and and
they'll be like well I'm a Libertarian
and I'm like oh okay you voted for Trump
yeah yeah you know so this guy was like
you know it seemed at first he was like
okay yeah fine whatever like I'll just
like volley one word answers back to you
and the little kid is just busy playing
on the Nintendo switch and so there she
keeps talking and she started and so I'm
now I'm like music off headphones still
in I'm just like listening off to the
side here
and she goes on and she's like look I
don't mean to sound like a straight
white woman and I was like oh oh and she
says
but I gotta tell you my friend like
these these things that she's saying are
like coming out of [__] out of
nowhere like nothing was prompting the
questions other than herself so she goes
I don't mean to sound like a straight
white woman but
my friend has an organization that could
barely get funny and you know who got
all of the funding the lgbtq community
and at first I was like I want to turn
on be like uh that is not at all
fact like barely scraping by many
organizations right now
and then outside of the fact that all
these people are under attack by
different you know laws trying to strip
rights away
and then she goes she's like I just feel
like there should be like a support
group or like an ally group for for for
straight white people and I was like oh
my God this is [__] crazy and then
she continues to talk about [__]
Earth
and so she continues to she continues to
talk about how you know the riots that
were happening because she's uh I was in
the north pack West right so she was
talking about Seattle and she was
talking about Portland and she goes
um
she said you know the last two and a
half years all these riots and stuff
like I'm not a republican but I was
super glad when they came in and they
started arresting people so I'm assuming
she was talking about either well it was
kind of confusing Portland OR Seattle
and where they were but she continues to
go on and talk about how you know this
Injustice and she was like I can barely
you know I used to walk for the last 20
years by this J crew downtown and now I
can't walk to J.Crew it's like why
aren't people like shopping local and
I'm like oh my God J.Crew is not local
okay that does that no that is not at
all why they shut down and then on top
of that
she continues to talk about you know
other stupid [__] the [__] thing that
kind of pissed me off the most was she
goes
um she was like yeah and this this
[__] well since I [__] she was
like this pronoun stuff people saying he
him his her they them whatever she goes
the pilot did you even notice the
Pilot's name tag had his name and then
he him I walked past the pilot didn't
even notice it because you know what I
wasn't [__] triggered before I walked
on the plane about that thing so she
goes yeah he him I get it you're a dude
you're a man why do you have to say that
to other people and it's like
why do you even care no one is no one is
forcing you to do to say to follow those
things it's just a recommendation and
also for that pilot to let other people
who might identify as something else to
say hey I accept you and this is a safe
space for the next X amount of hours
you're on the on the in the [__] air
just know that you can always trust me
right this is a political strategy
called riding the backlash
it's uh
all these [__] on the right wing like
these [__] in the chat right now
that are running their [__] super
mouths they all follow a guy by the name
Christopher rufo they do he's he is the
the flavored Azure the the the guy
that's gonna blow himself up in a few
weeks and disappear
but he right now is is the flavor of the
day and that's his strategy is right the
backlash Christopher Ruffo he's the guy
that invented all the CRT nonsense
that's that all comes from him
[__] what the hell is I don't know I am
never it
he he's he uh as part of the Manhattan
he's a fellow at the Manhattan Institute
and he writes an article in their
newspaper
and he's got a Twitter feed that he
links it all to and all these [__]
right Wingers for so they they quote his
misinformation all the [__] time but
that's what he said I mean he this is
why this guy's gonna blow himself the
[__] I'm not worried about this guy he's
going to go away he did an interview
with the New Yorker okay he's a [__]
right-wing activist and he goes and does
an interview with the New Yorker because
he's an attention [__] and they're
asking him directly I resemble that
remark
and that they asked him said you know
what's this all about he said you know
how do you do this he says well I ride
the backlash you know after George Floyd
was killed a lot of people were like oh
but he didn't you know he should have
complied and he should this that and the
other and he foments that he pushes that
he Stokes that and and and focuses on
White victimhood in every situation you
know he says okay something happened
five black cops beat the hell out of a
black guy
how can I make the whites victims in
this and then you saw it all over
Twitter you know all these white people
were like oh well you know somehow they
were the victim in that situation five
black cops beat the [__] out of one
black guy and somehow [__] Chad was
the victim hey hey uh you heard Marjorie
Taylor green just say that white men are
the most depressed uh the demographic in
this country Texas Paul you don't
believe her when she says that how dare
you
um I believe they believe that because
guys like [__] Christopher Ruffo
[__] skull [__] their heads and and
ride ride the backlash that's what they
do okay well skull [__] I I but I
would love to take 20 minutes on that
but I'm gonna have to move on here
um Marjorie Taylor green she I I love
how she starts these she thinks this
makes her smart thread like I mean this
is like this is like Donald Trump being
like page one right page two I'm gonna
say something really smart now because
it's in a thread okay yeah all right
Elon
um here's here's what again this thread
is really [__] long and it's really
[__] dumb and I'm not gonna read you
the whole thing but she is convinced she
is convinced that we need a national
divorce now now we went over her tweet
yesterday that people were freaking out
about but this this this trial tonight
has been talking about National divorce
before she even got served for her for
her actual divorce she's been talking
about it for years but here's what she
says she is why the left and right
should consider a national divorce oh
well here we go she's a Centrist now
um not a civil war but a legal agreement
to separate our ideological and
political disagreements by States while
maintaining our legal Union here's what
she means Texas fall she means white
States and black States that's what she
means
nowhere nowhere in any kind of form of
our country at any point in our history
have we had our states divided up on
borders based on ideological and
political disagreements other than our
congressional districts because
Republicans have done that and let me
tell you something I've been saying this
over and over and over again
if you want if you want a national
divorce I think we should lean into
couples therapy Marge and I think what
we should do is democrats should start
[__] gerrymandering the [__] out of
blue States any Democrat that has a set
of balls should be out in front of a
microphone every [__] day not saying
it like I say it I'm the clown I'm the
one that gets to say yay they're gonna
gerrymander say it in a way that makes
Republicans think about how they're
[__] gerrymandering let me tell you
something let me tell you something
about this National divorce [__] if if
we had couples therapies what I'm going
to start calling it in this country
where both couples participate in the
same [__] therapy of gerrymandering
and gerrymander the [__] [__] out of
blue states that is the only way I I I
commend Barack Obama and Eric Holder
trying to create this institution to try
to fight gerrymandering dudes it didn't
work it made it worse it made it worse
what you need to do is lean into it lean
into the gerrymandering show them that
we are willing to use their [__]
tactics to take power in this country to
push our woke ideology on them and then
they'll think hard about how [__]
gerrymandering doesn't [__] help
their ideology it hurts it in the long
run what we need to do is fight these
[__] in the fight that we're in
and that that is what this bonehead as
much as she has no [__] clue what
she's talking about because frankly even
if we did divide up red States and blue
States and divided them up they would be
[__] broke in a matter of minutes I
mean absolutely flat [__] broke they
wouldn't have schools they wouldn't have
infrastructure they wouldn't have jobs
no one would live in those [__]
States nobody they would look at the
demographics
look at the demographics okay you take
the red people out of the the blue
people out of the red States what's
their demographic college educated the
professionals the people yeah I mean and
then the demographic demographic of the
of the folks that are in that are
in [__] California that are Maga
they're
[__] morons they're [__] trailer
trash morons
you know and you swap that
the red states are [__] dead
overnight
guys I hate to do this but I have to run
that's fine we'll continue we'll
continue thanks for Texas wall for
joining us everyone and stay right here
we're gonna go right back to Martin
great to see you folks love you guys
we'll we'll give Texas ball a plug here
in a minute yeah I do want to jump on
something that so what people need to
understand here and I'm sure a lot of
the people in the comments in the
audience do know this is who pays whose
taxes right or whose taxes cover the
expenses of that state and when you
break it down you realize that red
states do a shitty job of covering their
own Tab and as a result blue states have
to come in because they're typically
generating more wealth or the economy is
doing better or they uh they have a
better system in place because it's run
by a Democrat I mean that those are just
the facts okay you can look at all the
data and all the stats you want and you
can try to refute my claim right now
but good [__] luck because what
you'll see is that blue States cover the
tab for red States oh taxes and cover
those in other states but let's go back
to the red state blue State thing
because that's really not what she's
saying right because there is no
ideology there is no idea there's no
clear I will say right there is no way
to clearly cut up like oh southern
belles right boom because you'll
actually notice that those states in the
southern region actually are blue right
right but because of gerrymandering it
shows up right here here's here's a
prime example um Georgia Texas ball
pointed it out earlier prime example of
the state being blue but it's also red
right that that state is very very
diverse meaning that it's the state that
Marjorie Taylor green is from even
though the part of the state that she
lives in is only white
in her district is only white because
they've made it that way doesn't mean
that it's it's a red State very few
states are the majority one or the other
right now it's very clear in the vote
sometimes it happens uh this happened
the other day when I was blaming Ohioans
uh for the uh the the train derailment
and people are pissed off that I was
blaming Ohioans because it looks like by
the way there's breaking news on that
okay well maybe we'll get to that I'd
like to talk about that if we can but um
I said I and someone in the comments was
mad at me because they're like oh
because I said stop voting for
republicans and they said they've
gerrymandered our state that's all
[__] do you you were so full of [__]
A governor's race is not gerrymandered a
[__] United States senator's race is
not gerrymandered that is [__] you
can't tell me that the lines around the
state are gerrymandered when the entire
State votes on a United States Senator
and a [__] Governor it's not
gerrymandered the problem is is
boneheads are being boneheads just like
this [__] bonehead talking about this
stuff now um let me see
again this is a lot of trash that she's
saying
um uh again here's here here's here's
one point that she has which is not a
good point it's just a point tragically
I think we the left and the right
meaning she is a right-wing [__]
freak she's pointing that out to be
quite honest there have reached in
Jesus Christ
and reconcilable differences now which
is the terminology that's used in a
divorce divorce paper well it was
literally heard divorce right but that's
what I'm saying is she's reading her
divorce papers and she's gone oh well
that's what we need nationally she's
like
[__] You on the big words I had trouble
with it I had trouble with it
exileable differences
I suck at reading what are you gonna do
fine it's just a good thing hey look do
the audience out there I'm a horrible
reader I'm a dumb [__] you're just lucky
I'm a liberal that's all I'm saying
you're just lucky I'm a liberal um but
this this trash keeps saying it's just
this trash goes on and on look at this
oh on and on and on and on with this
trash but it really is it is projection
it is her own issues right she's been
talking about it years I mean we know
that this woman is not faithful to her
country and by country I mean marriage
because she had multiple Affairs but I
mean I you know I would say that the
same is true to her country right like
if you really are loyal to your country
then you really would be a patriot you
wouldn't try to you know I don't know uh
active active sedition and try to
overthrow the government because you
didn't like the outcome of the election
that your your
orange
megalomaniac uh Trump humping flag
kissing uh small hands waving Donald
Trump
uh you know Lawson had a had a at a
complete [__]
tantrum right
but we have to realize that like she is
she is one you know like you said 100
projecting on to her own from her own
problems onto America right she was
never loyal in her marriage she was
never loyal to her country and is
whatever whoever is paying the most
money and has the most amount of
influence because just like Lauren
bobert Margie Taylor green [__] uh
George Santos all of these people they
seek these positions not because they
love this country they seek these
positions because they want Power they
want money and they want influence so
that they can better themselves and
their position in this country while
also keeping other people who are not
white or who not who do not identify
with these white supremacy uh white man
is better you should be thankful kind of
[__] if they don't agree with that
then you get on the bottom that's how it
goes and that's what all these people
are you know Thomas Massey [__] Paul
Go Star all of these people are not
loyal they do not love this the marriage
that is this country right we went
through [__] tough times in the civil
union or Civil War we were you know
still it the the the marriage that is
the United States right it's a Rocky one
we have fights all the time
but obviously democracy is the uh is
really the couple's therapy of it all
right it is really the thing that shall
let everyone speak and let everyone have
a voice
and give their perspective a divorce
would say your voice doesn't matter and
your tacos don't matter and that's what
the Republican party is trying to push
they're trying to push that they don't
support tacos I couldn't agree with Jan
Moore I support tacos and I support the
diversity of tacos to be quite honest
with you and the I mean I can make any I
can make any political topic around
tacos I'll just say that well that's
what we should do on Taco Tuesday from
now on
um
you you you invoked George Santos's name
which reminded me this whole interview
by the way did you really which reminded
me now there's a lot of there's a lot of
clips from it because it is George
Santos so like everything he says is
[__] dumb yeah like everything he
says was there one moment where he says
something that it isn't just like dude
you're a dumbass dude there is stuff in
here like he talks like there's Clips on
it there's actually a clip I want to
share uh that I haven't seen anyone do
most of this stuff is like do you have
flaming is Jewish no I don't have it on
me well okay let's watch this let's
watch this see if you can find it while
we're while we're perusing through this
portion how long is this interview by
the way the entirely the whole segment
is an hour long but she's a bunch of
[__] in Christ he has a bunch of
commercials so it's 42 minutes yeah it's
probably 40 some minutes honestly
because with TV you know you're gonna
get the 42 minutes with the commercial
breaks for an hour but this is this is
Pierce Morgan and you know [__] Pierce
Morgan to be quite honest with you [__]
him I
[__] that [__] but it is it is kind
of telling that George Santos decided to
do this with Pierce Morgan when I
started watching some of these clips I'm
like oh this makes sense why he would do
it with Piers Morgan but watch but it
didn't go it didn't go well no no no
well I'm I'm saying I'm saying that was
intentional I'm saying he knew an
interview he knew an interview with a
serious reporter would have went real
would have went Way South with Pierce
Morgan it's kind of like it's kind of
like a clown interviewing a clown why
he's a clown right and in the interview
he tries to make these jokes against
Biden and you know be like oh well
Biden's actually the number one you know
biggest liar
like he's trying to find there are
moments in the interview where George
Santos is trying to relate and throw
other people under the bus or say it's
just how the [__] political machine
works or Joe Biden is or Joe Biden that
and Pierce Morgan for the most part he's
like hey look I have my own references
but you you're done you said your own
thing was that you said you were Jewish
and he goes I never said I was Jewish
and he's like you literally just said
you were Jewish you claimed this because
of your family side it's [__] bananas
I'm gonna have to do a breakdown in this
whole interview because uh let me tell
you let me tell you you know we could
just we could do a special stream where
we just we just watched it would take
about three hours to get through it
probably with commentary but let's let's
watch this short little clip see if you
can find that other yeah that you want
to show you never go to Masters in
Business at New York no no like I said
no right
I mean again
I don't think people would find this out
you know Pierce not after I you're not
wanting to be like a reality TV no no I
understand
you know if you're going on Celebrity
Apprentice which I went on right it
doesn't matter
see what I mean by Pierce Morgan was the
perfect person to do this and the reason
why is because is because now now people
cannot accuse George Santos of lying
about his lies that that is what they're
trying to Rebrand him folks as just a
republican I've been telling you this
I've been telling you this since this
[__] came in the news we saw the
other day some [__] from
Tennessee is just as big of a liar as
George Santos but he's a straight white
dude so no one [__] paid attention to
that Santos has got he's got a Brazilian
last name and he's supposedly gay so
right away they seize on him they seize
on him and the Republicans are the ones
who attacked him first it wasn't the
Democrats it was the Republicans in his
[__] District that are like get out
[__] get the [__] out because he duped
them but Pierce Morgan is the perfect
clown for this clown show and that's why
they did it this way because a real
reporter would have not done this back
and forth where he's like yeah well I
like on the Celebrity Apprentice because
I was on the celebrity
like the humble The Humble brag look if
you were if you were embellishing you
know like we're all in Celebrity app
practice and you say these things
because you want to sound better but you
flat out lied
and I mean there were moments where I
watched this interview and I'm like ah
you could have pushed a little harder
but also I mean you know for the sake of
the interview I thought it was good that
a lot of the stuff got brought up and he
was challenged at points right
I have I have to say that Pierce Morgan
is a [__] clown and that's why they
had him do this because if you would
have had someone real a real [__]
journalist a real [__] person who
knows how to interview someone like this
not just play because Pierce Morgan is
doing this for his own [__]
benefits I mean this is pure for Pierce
Morgan's [__] benefit that [__]
scumbag he's not doing it for the
American people he's not doing it to get
the truth out there yeah he's doing it
just like he did the Trump interview
same stupid ass [__] Pierce Morgan but
um let's continue with this one did you
get the other one yeah okay let's let's
see what else they say in this clue so
nobody cares right but to run for
Congress of the United States and to
just tell blatant lies about even your
academic record I'm just struck not
necessarily that a politician would lie
but that you would think no one would
find out well I I'll humor you this I
ran in 2020 for the same exact seat
um for Congress and I got away with it
then and I guess
fine well that's honest stupid
oh my God Pierce Morgan says okay well
okay well that's honest
that's an excuse you don't lie then work
is going to exonerate
the same logic that George Santos uses
here which is I did it in 2020
and nobody stopped me then
so I did it again I don't see a problem
nobody stopped me along the way
so what what I see here is the same
excuse that you hear from Audrey Taylor
green who says Ah trained derailments
happen all the time [__] spills people
die it's whatever
when you hear that you should probably
say uh how do we avoid that right maybe
we invest in infrastructure regulation
regulation right regulation would be the
good idea that would be the thing that
we do make sure we regulate toxic
chemicals and people transporting toxic
chemists like in Tucson Arizona there
was also another one it was nitric acid
that came out that no one is really
talking about I'm I'm going to end up
doing what was that on on this whole
train
[__] you know that's happening
because it's a lot of and a lot of it is
distraction right just like the balloon
it's all distraction to place blame and
now Biden is actually taking over uh
well having the EPA take over
um because dewine and the rest of these
Republicans that's a breaking news
that's the breaking news and so he's
actually having the EPA take over
because the wine and and JD Vance and
all these other people who are busy by
the way the same day that the train
derailment happened February 3rd JD
Vance is having with a [__] gun point
at the sky like he's going to shoot down
this the Chinese spy Bloom that same
time it took him 10 days to release a
statement from his office talking about
the trained derailment why did he just
shoot the train why didn't you just
shoot the train maybe he did shoot me
you know what I'm just saying maybe I'm
just saying he shot the Spy balloon and
the bullet fell because you know
whatever goes up comes down hits the
train and cause a derailment can we get
can we get someone to email email JD
Vance's official office for me so we can
get him on the show so I can ask him why
he didn't shoot at the plane like he was
going to shoot at the balloon right I
want to answer that question that's a
good question I don't know
yeah so thankfully why the [__] didn't
you use your gun I mean you could have
you totally could have stopped
everything with the gun because gun
solves all the problems I mean we all
know this now so what you're saying is
not only do we have balloonatics now
they've turned into trainatics trainer
ticks trainer ticks okay well or
derailitis derail attack hey that's even
better derail ticks um here here's the
little toys
20 minutes in yeah yeah this is 20
minutes in I think it's just a few it's
like a couple minutes of him but this is
him this is a clip that nobody's talking
about and I'm going to make a I'm going
to do a little snippet of this
he's talking about friends of pets
United okay
friends of pets United is the
organization that he started and he ran
okay keep that in mind it is his
organization so what he's about to say
right here
is not going to be surprising
because you're gonna be like oh that
totally makes sense why he would say
what he's about to say but the fact that
now he's trying to change the narrative
is what I find funny and this is the
first time we've heard him go into this
I guess level of detail which is not
much but the excuse he gives
um I just want to point out I missed
something on the JD Vance talk JD Vance
is a [__] oh sorry sorry about that
I forgot 100 now we can move on to the
George Santos clip because yes JD Vance
is a [__] Joseph saved two and a
half thousand dogs and cats over a
five-year period that true that's true
um but I wasn't alone in in the
operation uh I had there was a multitude
of people we were all volunteers I was
the operator I was one of the I think we
were seven Founders if I'm not mistaken
between New York and New Jersey uh my
advocacy in animal uh welfare and animal
rights is that stems from my childhood
I've always very compassion towards
animals I own four dogs at home they're
all rescues to to one sort I call it the
home of Misfits they're all unwanted
three legs heart murmur you know issues
like that and um
now everybody is after all the
revelations about the organization I
wasn't in charge of any of the I mean
the weird thing is there were no social
media accounts for it no titles were all
deleted well there were no the ones
anyone could find no tax records no
evidence of the charity being registered
in either New York or New Jersey they
did run one fundraiser with the rescue
group in New Jersey in 2017 for which
you charged a 50 entry fee but the group
would stage the event that had never
received any funds and I can attest that
that is not true the funds all ran
through through the group and the the
post of the of the facility was who was
in charge of all of our of our filings
so this came to a surprise as much what
happened to the tax records to the
social media I I was I wasn't in charge
of any of that it was never set up as a
charity well I I wouldn't know that I
was the operator I was the guy putting
cats out of the streets into my car
taking them together
would you say you're the operator of
this of this foundation and there's
literally no record of any of it
it doesn't doesn't there's much
credibility to your operational skills
like
so I mean I mean so yeah so that's the
that's the that's like the core of it
right there but the idea that George
Santos
is now claiming he goes there were seven
Founders and if you actually watch the
interview and I'll do a what was that on
this because it's so [__] crazy what
he says
but inside this interview he Pierce
Morgan goes okay so who would have
access to this other stuff right like
how do we follow up and he goes oh you
have to be one of the other Founders he
goes well can you
give me the names and it goes oh I don't
remember who might have who was
so now George Sanders is making up this
idea that there were seven founders
between New York and New Jersey
and that the paperwork was not actually
him despite George Santos being the
money man remember he said he was a Wall
Street whiz and all this stuff which he
also gets called out by Pierce Morgan's
interview so now he's saying oh you know
what I actually wasn't involved in the
day-to-day operations even though I was
the operations manager I was picking up
dogs and taking them here and there and
also losing dogs if anyone remembers the
story I told and also broke the story on
what was that which I'll probably go
into uh when I do this one but the idea
that George Santos now is like oh you
know what I actually I was just a
volunteer and it wasn't my organization
kind of thing or even though it is his
organization he was the CEO president
co-founder or founder and now he's
trying to claim that oh you know what it
was this it was one of these other other
people who I can't name you right now on
TV they're AI they're probably they're
it's completely made up it's uh
you know and it really you imagine
George Santos lying can you imagine yeah
come on
um
the dogs ate his paperwork coming from I
mean it really is that excuse you know
it the dogs ate the filings and just
know I've looked up I've looked up
business records in New York New Jersey
Delaware Florida nothing I I have to say
I know um your your work your work goes
Untold sometimes but like over the last
month Gabe Sanchez literally has been
working his ass off to try to figure out
who the [__] is George Santas like
literally here's another little fun fact
for you I would I had a well before
before the text message is kind of
stopped
me and another person were having a text
message conversation with George Santos
what and yeah we're having no no no no
no no no no you you mean you mean
another George Santos not not Anthony
not Anthony the volder it was it was
Anthony Boulder uh but we were having we
were legitimately we're having a text
message conversation and I will probably
I'll probably I'll I'll do I'll make a
video about that where he shares here's
the thing the timing of his text
messages to us
to when he starts sharing a photo of his
golden retriever he sent us text
messages three to four minutes before he
sent these tweets he's like oh here's my
dog it's in surgery we knew his dog got
surgery on Friday and then on Monday he
releases this tweet for like Monday
afternoon being like oh here's my old
nine-year-old uh golden retriever this
and that the line about the house of
Misfits he lives with in a house of
Misfits he [__] said that in a text
message to us on Friday night before did
he know did he know it was you texting
him no I mean well we told him we told
him because he sent you wait wait wait
wait wait you lied to him I never said
who I was I understand who I was
I I had someone sent it send a text
message to say can you give us comment
on this story which was my story yeah
about the two dogs going missing then
what was that you did yeah and what was
that he could not give comment he said
uh the the organization is it's uh
defamation and it's a smear campaign and
all this stuff would not comment on the
legitimacy of it and then try to say oh
you know what actually the organization
can't be trusted uh yeah George Sanchez
is working his picture I mean honestly
he's testing me because I'm like what I
what I see Happening Here is he tried to
make a joke if anyone picked it up he
tried to hit this like heartstring
moment where he talks like oh I I like
to say that I'm in a house full of
Misfits I got a dog with three legs and
this a heart murmur or that Pierce
Morgan's like uh-huh and and the smile
jokiness of it he immediately collapses
and goes well I actually wasn't in
charge of this stuff I didn't actually
do this in the same way that he tried to
deny
his involvement at you know uh Citibank
and Goldman Sachs and how he was Jewish
but not Jewish you know kind of thing
it's a [__] this is cool interview is
[__] crazy the best part about this
whole thing is George Santos is just an
ignorant son of a [__] he's just an
ignorant son of a [__] and he's not
he's not outside the realm of any
regular Republican and I I know a lot of
people make you know these um they want
him to be the liar of all liars but he's
just a Republican and more than anything
when Gabe sends me some stuff
I'm like yep just typical everyday
average Republican [__] like just what I
thought
um P2 on
on YouTube says how dare you lie to
honest George Sanchez
oh my God I just I can't get enough of
it listen I wanted to show a clip of
Tucker Carlson yeah well you got time
yeah I got time oh okay great we'll go a
little longer for this clip I didn't
know it because it's gonna take a minute
because I'm I'm gonna talk about this
[__] that's fine um that's fine we can
talk about it this has to do with Russia
and of course he's Putin's a little
[__]
[Music]
um Tucker is yeah um now I said to this
video if you're supposed to say I would
also say George Santos is probably
Putin's [__] too well I mean we know
well I definitely know Paul gosar is
Trump trump I mean can we just say
Republicans not only are just they're
Liars they're also [__] ass Putin
[__] can we just oh yes
yeah we're getting we're getting way too
many nicknames um but this guy
definitely is a [__] ass [__] and he's
definitely pooped [__] ass [__] this
is if you're still standing around
wondering why part of the country is is
[__] is
is [__] supporting Putin and the
stupid propaganda this is this is why
right here listen to this stupid [__]
people used to tell you that Donald
Trump was stupid remember that he's he
people still say that a lot of people
are saying Gabe every time he makes a
video or sends out a truth on Truth
social a lot of people we are reminded
how much of a [__] idiot Donald Trump
is
now we're not gonna sit here and tell
you it was a smart idea to turn the
White House over to Jared Kushner it was
not but it's all was that a knock at
Jared Kushner it feels like Tucker
Carlson has something against jerk and I
can't put my I can't put my nose on it
exactly what it is that he would hate
Jared Kushner for I'm not really sure if
it's how issues he is or I'm not really
sure maybe it is Tucker's little I don't
know because if you've have you ever
watched neo-nazis talk about Trump and
they're like how he's the Savior and
he's done a lot for white power and then
at one point someone will ask and I
think it's a vice interview is one of
them that's really good where they're
talking to like a Neo-Nazi group leader
and they're like what about what about
Ivanka Trump and Jerry Kushner and I
mean they just go red
just like that and they're like oh those
Jews like the anti-Semitism just
absolutely controls their inner being I
almost I don't I don't know for sure but
it feels like yeah it's like uh it's uh
definitely like we got away with the
anti-Semitism live on the air right you
know and then and then yeah like that
because his obviously Counterpoint would
be like oh I wasn't talking about him
being Jewish guys I was talking about
him you know uh botching this or Messing
this up or being Jewish yeah I'm gonna
dying about him being Jewish I was
talking about you
right yeah it does have that little tone
of anti-Semitism I'm just saying let's
keep going also true for being honest
and we should be that Donald Trump had
far wiser instincts about American
foreign policy than any leader in at
least a generation and what he means by
that is he loved [__] autocrats he
loved dictators he loves Kim Jong-un he
loves vitaminophobia he loves
islamophobia he loves Banning Muslims
from the U.S right like that all the
white power stuff all the white power
stuff that Tucker Carlson loves Trump
did that that's why Taco Carl I mean
same you know Tucker Carlson's another
person who very much so believes in a
national divorce right he's the guy
that'd be with Margaret Taylor green
saying yes let's get a divorce you know
we should [__] split this too like
that's I mean
Tucker Carlson is because again we
learned and I haven't even gone through
all the fox files but the fox files show
you how they you know
explicitly called out these people as
[__] lunatics and idiots and deranged
this and all this brought him on the
show because they knew what they would
say but also didn't also believe in what
they were saying because we saw that if
you played the middle ground like you
weren't crazy you know I'm not crazy
they're The Crazy Ones right well and
it's what Tucker Carlson does best are
we supposed to are we supposed to just
not believe Sydney pal are we just
supposed to believe that she's a lunatic
are we just supposed to believe that
Donald Trump is what they say he is is
an idiot and dumb and not capable of
governing are we just supposed to
believe that at face value are we
supposed to question it do you see what
he does that's what the [__] he does the
reason why here's a reason let me let me
tell you the reason why I'm good at
forming the stupid questions that Tucker
Carlson does and and I know this is
going to piss a lot of people off and it
may scare some people away but I don't
give a [__] it's because I know what
propaganda is
I'm very good at it and Tucker Carlson
is very [__] good at go look up the
word propaganda it's not scary it's
scary when someone like Tucker Carlson
has a microphone that he has and has the
capability of pushing propaganda on
[__] dummies in this country
when you're propagating lies it has an
effect on our national [__] structure
and political body it really truly does
and I don't know if you know this but
the reason why so many people in this
country [__] love Putin is because of
this nonsense listen
and he did it without the help of anyone
none of his advisors wanted to hear his
use on foreign policy in fact they
desperately wanted Trump to be quiet but
Trump wouldn't what's the point of NATO
he asked nearly 30 years after that
that's not what he asked that's what
Tucker Carlson is asking again Trump
said NATO's terrible NATO sucks Trump
never asked a question in his entire
[__] life because he's not curious
about anything yeah other than himself
the reason why Tucker Carlson is so good
at this is what he just did he put a
question that never entered Donald
Trump's mouth into his mouth as if
Donald Trump said it well he's pair he's
you know he's taking because what he's
doing is he taking little tiny bits of
truth right Donald Trump
talking about NATO and saying how
they're terrible and then paraphrasing
that into a question so he's coupling
some truth and throwing it within this
uh shell of [__] right by saying
why does NATO even exist right why do we
have it that's kind of crazy I'm just
asking questions right well again I'm
sure someone will clip the part where I
said I'm really good at propaganda I'm
sure they'll clip that part yeah
actually you know what let me make it
bigger so you can clip me bigger when
I'm saying I'm really good at propaganda
that way they can yeah there it is yeah
yeah yeah time to stamp it that way you
can yeah why not [__] it you know what
what am I gonna do
let's continue
with Tucker's propaganda follow the
Soviet Union no one in Washington could
answer him shut up racist they replied
but Trump just kept going in his trumpy
way why would we fight the trumpy
wouldn't making Russia our enemy just
drive Putin into the arms of China and
create the most powerful and dangerous
anti-American Bloc in history see and
this is where Tucker's trying to raise
his propaganda and what he does is he
leads the ignorant sheep to this moment
where they're like yeah that is the no
that's not the question that's the
dumbest question I've ever heard of in
my life as if China
that that the craziest part about it all
is that President XI is some kind of
schlub and that and that he is beholden
to Putin or [__] Trump and really the
most the most powerful [__] autocrat
in the world is G that that Gigi ping is
the most powerful autocrat in the entire
world at this point at this moment why
do you think Donald Trump is always like
I love that guy oh man I want to be just
like him because right I want to be king
I want to be dictator XI I mean he when
he talks about Gigi ping and his
lifetime presidency it's almost like he
doesn't even need to take Viagra to get
his little mushroom oh yeah he gets so
yeah I mean what you see Tucker Carlson
doing right now is he's probing the idea
right he's putting it out there saying
that other people are saying you know
right the thing with Donald Trump is
Donald Trump says many people are saying
this and typically it's just he himself
and well I right like me myself and I
are the many people that are saying this
thing and then you put it out there and
you say enough times and a lot of people
believe that is actually what people are
saying right and that is what his
followers believe and then on Tucker
Carlson's show he will rephrase the
questions pivot it this way then say oh
well you know
why is it so bad some people are asking
these questions I'm just asking
questions I'm just an inquisitive person
you know yeah and so you see that you
finally you I mean not finally but you
see this idea that Tucker Carlson is
probing American Minds right wing
American Minds with the idea of hey what
do you think about this foreign policy
what do you think would happen if China
and Russia come together because
America's anti-russia in America is a
bad one because Russia is a good one and
before we said communist China but now
China is teaming up with Russia and
enemy and my enemy is my friend and so
it's like they should team up because
America's being a big bad bully right
now and Biden is the big bully that is
charging us forward but he's winning but
he's weak and he's weak and he's in a
basement I don't understand but he's
also walking while Sirens are happening
in Ukraine but the thing is
China doesn't want to do [__] with
Russia Russia doesn't want to do a chit
with China well maybe who knows in terms
of force but then you've got people like
Tucker Carlson and right wing news who
are just probing just asking questions
we're just asking questions we just want
to see what you guys think
just because the idea is that if they
throw it out there enough times to say
some people they're saying he's saying
uh you know military experts are are
saying this whatever it might be
he wants enough people then to be
talking about it right it's this idea
that if I talk about enough and say
other people are talking about it then
other people are going to talk about it
and now there's a lot of people talking
about it and so when the idea of these
two you know forces coming together
against America
they've now been primed to understand
that oh you know what that's actually
not a bad thing if they come against
America it's really they're going
against Joe Biden and if they help take
out Joe Biden no Biden the enemy yeah
exactly Joe Biden it's not it's not
America it's not like hey look if they
shoot one person in the house right or
whatever right they murder one person
they're trying to get away with that
right it's like oh it's not it's not
ever everyone's not bad right it's just
a one person and so
well I mean this is how fascists think
but here's a good story about
information because I said I'm really
good at propaganda and again that's
probably someone's going to clip that
eventually
um if especially if I say it enough
times especially if people are saying
that I'm gonna probably uh
all everyone's saying it I mean I many
people are saying many people are Tony
is good and propaganda many people are
saying that many people like two uh
right now
um but but here's how information Works
here's a little story and I told this uh
in the moment I go I wouldn't help the
friend move into his house like unload
his U-Haul you know what I mean and
another one of his friends showed up I
don't know the guy first time I ever met
him he's kind of young meaning younger
than I am he's in his 20s right he said
he's he hasn't really got out into the
world yet and it was right after like a
day after
um Paul Pelosi got smashed in the head
with a hammer by a manga assassin right
by a trump upped white dude who wanted
to kill Nancy Pelosi and ended up just
being Paul in the house smashing the man
with a hammer it's like the day it was
like the day after that happened now we
were unloading and of course this gang
is a [__] you know he's on Facebook
he's a moglodyte he's a bonehead he's a
trumped up white dude right and I'm
trying to talk some sense into this
stupid number [__] and he starts
talking about Paul Pelosi and at the at
that point you gotta remember the day
after it happened they were like oh he
was naked they were having sex and right
all kinds of just crazy [__] because
Tucker Carlson's on Fox she's like were
they having sex were they were they gay
lovers what we need to know this the the
police department in San Francisco is
not telling us why are they not telling
us this stuff like interjecting all
these ideas
now later we were carrying the TV into
the basement
and and we I I think I had the TV or as
a TV stand something about the TV
carrying it into my friend's basement
where it was
in theory be
and he says yeah now he can launch all
his Fox News down here my friend is a
liberal yeah
this guy is not and I said I said oh you
watch Fox News dude he said well
actually I don't I just knew that would
trigger you and I said it's funny
because I'm not triggered I said what
you don't understand is how information
Works he said what do you mean I said
you really don't watch Fox News he said
no I don't watch Fox News I said but not
but 15 minutes ago
you repeated every single thing that Fox
News said right about the Paul Pelosi
Hammer attack without any without ever
watching Fox News without ever watching
it I said the thing that makes you
really dumb and ignorant isn't that you
watch Fox News or don't watch Fox News
it's that you don't understand how
information Works you're not really
clear on how it works and how it's
delivered to you and how you're being
mind [__] by by Fox News without even
having to watch it and when I explained
it to him for about five seconds oh man
for about five seconds I had this guy I
had him he was on the hook and he was
like oh my God maybe I nope nope not
gonna do it no no no no I'm way too
white I'm way too white for that I mean
he just he just turned he just turned
but that is truly how information works
and what you're saying is true this is
exactly why he does this stuff Dr
Carlson that is and I want to show you
something that Paul I don't know if this
is a real picture or not I don't I don't
know it seems like a real t-shirt it
says I'd rather be a Russian than a
Democrat I don't know Rio who's wearing
it or not but I'm just oh staying I'm
just saying
rather be a Russian than a Democrat
right please I tweeted this please I I
retweeted so go to my timeline if you
want to grab this
um and please don't don't spread this
around the internet that would be yeah
sure that would be totally a response
because this is this is this looks like
disinformation or misinformation
um so it would be totally totally not
right to spread this
that oh my God what
minutes over we're 17 minutes over I I
appreciate the audience sticking around
uh for the Tucker Carlson clip and Gabe
Sanchez we're glad to have you back yeah
everyone missed you yesterday well what
do you got for what was that give us
give us a little plug here uh yeah so uh
what was that I've got uh upcoming
episodes are gonna be focused on one the
next one I think is going to be Lauren
bobert attempting to attack Rachel
Maddow on Twitter and then just getting
owned I mean that's a really bad mistake
I would have yeah that was a really I
mean like here's the thing Rachel Maddow
didn't even have to comment on it it was
the fact that Lauren bober was like oh
they're all uh everyone learned or
Biden's regime learned how to govern
from Rachel Maddow yeah she's [__]
smart dude she's a [__] road scholar
not like Amy Coney Barrett who was a
Rhodes college graduate right a Rhodes
Scholar
but anyway so I've got one coming up
about that I've also I'm gonna do one
about this train derailment
um in this distraction I'll probably
throw in the Spy balloons to go with the
theme of distraction uh and then uh and
then oh and then obviously this George
Santos interview there's other like
little episodes I do along the way which
are who the [__] is George Santos but
this is like they're like mini what
they're like mini like here's the
synopsis of things that happened in like
the last week or last two weeks I cover
I've got another one that's coming out
just to keep up just to keep up because
there's always something every week
right so I'll have another full full
length what was that
um that'll probably be dedicated to
George Santos on this interview
specifically just for the [__] that he
said uh but there's always little things
that come up so will everyone go to go
to uh patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
check out what was that over there
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez uh and see
what's coming up with the what was that
and the additional benefits and uh Early
Access and behind the scenes access you
get on patreon.com I also I also heard
that somebody may have had issues
yesterday trying to do it so they
weren't able to
um to subscribe and I think when I when
I looked online uh basically you could
try two things one you could try logging
out logging back in you could try uh
logging in on a different advice a
device
um or are you talking about patreon yeah
it sounded like somebody I I was uh I
think there's an update in the app I
believe but also if
um because I have patreon too and I want
to thank everyone for getting over 100
yesterday that was pretty cool and our
next goal is 150 but on my patreon and
maybe we should talk about this for a
second but if you doubt make sure you
download the patreon app
um if you're gonna be on patreon and I
discovered this once I open up my
patreon and the reason why is because
I'm posting stuff over there like in the
mornings I post when the show's coming
on if I find a meme I'll I'll post
something like I announced you were
coming back in Texas Paul was going to
join us today
um for sure once I once I confirm those
things and so I'm posting stuff over
there and I'm posting early social media
but if if you're out there and you're
joining the patreon or you're interested
in joining patreon minor games either
way make sure you download the app on
your phone because it's almost like a
social media app
um or you should look at it that way
that's kind of how I'm looking at it
yeah like as I'm posting and responding
and trying to get to your your direct
your DMs because a lot of people sent me
DMS right I'm trying to respond to those
so I use the app I mean I use it on my
computer too but I use the app a lot
when I'm on the go so download the
patreon app and make sure it's updated
that might be part of the problem if
you're if you're not doing that so go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or what
was thatshow.com again it's patreon.com
I am Gabe Santos you can watch it for
free but you get all the extras yeah
over there on patreon and it helps I put
little designs in there I'll let you
know upcoming episodes stuff that
happens outside the studio which is just
this area right here it's behind the
scenes you don't show them any like um
it's not like um like an only fans thing
is it I'm just wondering I'm if you pay
enough money oh okay well I was thinking
about doing an only fans type tier on
mine you know yeah I don't know I don't
know maybe look I'll show I'll show real
skin
ah we're attention [__] it happens it
happens also I want to tell you uh go
visit Texas Paul
realtexaspaul.com the link is down in
the description on YouTube
um so go check out Texas Paul we think
Texas ball he had to run I'm not sure
why I hope everything's okay over there
um maybe he just had to uh you know go
um but uh
but um I hope everything's okay and also
subscribe to the YouTube channel we're
getting so close
and to our goal of 20 000 we're over 14.
now we're so close I know it feels like
like six thousand that's a lot it's not
really that many it's not really that
many there's 14 over 14 000 of you if if
you just get a half a person I don't
know if you know a half a person but if
you just get a half a person
to come uh subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast on YouTube we'll get to
20 000 quick fast and in a hurry
also download every single episode of
the Tony Michaels podcast on Apple
Spotify and Google and you can also
watch it on the up wires YouTube channel
just go to upwire.com you can follow the
link there and make sure if you're an
Amazon Prime user you go subscribe to it
on Twitch if you log into twitch game
Sanchez with your Prime account you get
one free subscription and you can use
that subscription to the Tony Michaels
podcast which helps us keep going and
Amanda you want three hours that helps
us get the three hours out there because
it really is not a timing thing as you
noticed we can do three hours pretty
easy it's more of a this is our day job
this is our jab and we got we gotta try
to pay the bills
Jared Benton
oh sorry Jared Brenton yeah uh thank you
so much he just says join the patron
just join the patreon thank you so much
we need like
if people join live on the show they get
a call out there you know I think
there's probably a tool that we can use
automated thing but you know I'm I'm
[__] yeah
I'm horrible at that
um and and see I'm getting direct
messages from patreon as we speak my
notifications again
so go download the patreon app I'm dead
serious Go download the patreon app on
your phone you don't have to join right
away
because I think your lowest year is five
bucks my lowest tier is five bucks and I
want to explain that because I I tried
to explain that last week when you
weren't here
um is the reason why we have two
separate ones mine is for my additional
content that I make for you on patreon
like I give you the Early Access to
social media I do the Sunday rant
um I'm posting stuff over there I'm
interacting with you guys over there so
that's what that is and then we're gonna
do the ask me anything
um we're gonna have the the patreon
parties there's gonna be a lot of stuff
that we're gonna do over there but yours
is for what was that so when you join
Gabe's understand that that your funds
if you have the money to join this
patreon that is going towards that
content that is very that's very
important and your money to me is going
towards my content that I'm giving you
on patreon so that's the support that
you're giving that's why we have two
separate ones because in a few people
that were like why you have separate
ones it's because we're doing two
separate things
um in our patrons but it keeps us in
this seat as well because this is like
our job commentaries our job so so we're
trying to make a living and this show is
free and we want to keep it free for
everyone to listen to two hours a day
hopefully Amanda you'll get your wish
soon
um for three hours maybe Gabe will only
be here for an hour and a half too but I
I might be here for three full hours
every day so hopefully you get your wish
soon so I'm hoping for 2024 because we
need to keep pushing we need to keep
leaning into democracy and also keep
supporting us I know that sounds crazy
that we're like
but it is our living right it's our
living so go to
store.thetonymichaels.com
store.the20michaels.com get some Surf's
Up merch and Gabe Sanchez uh is
promising me this week that we're gonna
have this PAB 45. we got two design
thoughts that we have one that you're
working on one that we're trying to put
together on another thing so
um well give us your word Gabe Sanchez
that this week I'm putting you on the
spot this week we'll have this this week
this week we will get a EAB 45 shirt I
really I was hoping the weekend but you
got busy it became it became a whole
yeah
it happened all right everyone at same
time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon